THE SUMMIT TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
UNTIL WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM --
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ANOTHER
SENATOR BELT COME ON UP.
WHAT THE?
COURT.
SO SHAKE YOU HAVE TO GO START
WITH THE SP ONE ONE ONE NINE
PLEASE [inaudible]
YEAH.
OF YOUR FOR ISRAEL.
I'M SORRY A FOR BOB --
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE TO PRESENT THE
S. B. O. --
ONE ONE ONE NINE THIS IS --
PRETTY MUCH A COMMON SENSE --
MEASURE --
IT IT --
REVISES EXISTING ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS --
WITHIN THE LOW CARBON TRANSIT
OPERATIONS PROGRAM FOUND.
WE CALL THAT THE LC TOP FUN.
AND WHAT IT DOES THIS BILL DOES.
IS ALLOWS MORE STUDENTS TO
QUALIFY FOR FREE.
OR REDUCED TRANSIT FARES --
THERE ARE PARAMETERS IN THE
STATUTE AROUND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY REQUIREMENTS --
ARE CURRENTLY LIMITED AND YOUR
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS TO
SITUATIONS.
WHERE THE INVESTMENT OF COURAGE
DIRECTLY AND HOLY WITH IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY --
THIS RESTRAINS --
THESE TRANSIT FARES INTO IN A
WAY THAT WE DON'T REALLY INTEND.
BECAUSE WHAT WE WANTED DO IS GET
ON THE BUS [inaudible]
AND GO. TO OF SCHOOL.
AND KNOW THIS WOULD ALLOW THAT
ESSENTIALLY [inaudible]
SO -- THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO UNVEIL VESTED IN THE
LC TOP FUNDING.
ACROSS --
THREE ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL
AREAS AND COMPLIANCE WITH THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
IN ORDER TO BENEFIT THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHICH
IS.
OUR CURRENT LAW.
FIRST ARE TRANSIT FARE SUBSIDIES
INCLUDING STUDENT TRANSIT PASSES.
FOR ES SECONDLY TRANSIT --
CONNECTIONS TO MAJOR EMPLOYMENT
AREAS EDUCATIONAL OR MEDICAL
FACILITIES FOR RESIDENTS OF
DISADVANTAGE.
OR LONG COMMUNITIES.
AND THREE THE TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS REDUCING EMISSIONS
OF GREENHOUSE GASES --
AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
WITNESSES.
IS TO KEEP YOUR NAME HERE
REPRESENT PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE NOT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
THAT WE ARE THE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
SENATOR BILL FOR GETTING UP TO
SPEED ON THIS VERY QUICKLY --
HE IS OUR OUR OUR NEW AUTHOR AND
HAS SOME HISTORY WITH CARRYING
LC TOP REFORM BILLS IN THE PAST.
I SB ELEVEN NINETEEN WOULD MAKE
CHANGES TO THE LOW CARBON
TRANSIT OPERATIONS PROGRAM A
FORMULA PROGRAM FUNDED BY CAP
AND TRADE THAT SENDS MONEY TO
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S TRANSIT
SYSTEMS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OF
THE PROGRAM AWARDED
APPROXIMATELY NINETY SIX MILLION
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED OPERATORS.
WE BETTER DO THIS PROGRAM IS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND OUR
MEMBERS CONTINUE TO FACE SOME
CHALLENGES WITH ITS
IMPLEMENTATION.
AS NOTED BY SENATOR BILL THE
BILL WOULD PROVIDE RELIEF FROM
THE BILL'S DISADVANTAGED
COMMUTER CHOIR MINTS FOR CERTAIN
EXPEDITOR TYPES AND THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF LAYING OUT THE
PARTICULARS OF THE LAW.
AND THE DIFFICULTIES ARE TRADE
SYSTEMS ENCOUNTER.
IF ENACTED WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE TRANSIT AGENCIES
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED
TO WHO TO PROVIDE IMPROVED AND
EXPANDED TRANSIT SERVICE WHILE
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
AND MORE EFFECTIVELY SERVING LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
INDIVIDUALS FROM AREAS
CONSIDERED DISADVANTAGED. TO PUT
A FINER POINT ON THIS LA METRO
THE LARGEST TRANSIT SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IT RECEIVES ABOUT A
QUARTER OF ALL THE PROGRAM FUNDS --
AND CONDUCTED A RECENT BUS RIDER
SURVEY THAT SHOWED ALMOST 75% OF
THEIR BUS RIDERS REPORTED HAVING
AN ANNUAL HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THEREFORE ALMOST ANY INVESTMENT
YOU MAKE ON METROS BUS NETWORK
IS GENERALLY GOING TO HELP THE
COMMUNITIES THIS PROGRAM
INTENSELY.
IN SAN DIEGO 64% OF THE WRITERS
REPORT HOUSEHOLD INCOMES OF LESS
THAN FORTY THOUSAND IN SAN
FRANCISCO HALF OF THE WRITERS
REPORT HOUSEHOLD INCOMES OF LESS
THAN.
FIFTY THOUSAND AND WITH VERY FEW
EXCEPTIONS WE SEE SIMILAR
RESULTS ACROSS MOST OF OUR
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR HIGH VOTE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THEY KILL
REMINDER WITNESSES THERE'S AN
AYE RECOMMENDATION.
MORNING ONE GOES CO SPONSOR.
I THINK MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
WE ARE I WON THE CO SPONSORS AND
WE TO I'M THINK THIS WILL
STREAMLINE.
AND REDUCE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN FOR A CITY TO BE ABLE TO
HELP THE DOCKS AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THREE I DON'T MISS
YOUR MEMBERS JOSHUA SHAW FOR THE
SENATORS MUCH UPON TRANSIT
DISTRICT 70% OF OUR WRITERS HAVE
A HOUSEHOLD NCOME OF LESS THAN
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND YEAR AND WE
NEED TO SERVE ALL THOSE AREAS
NOT JUST THE ONE CENSUS TRACK IN
OUR DISTRICT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU TO KEEP.
I STEVE WELCOMED AT THE ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT
THE NAPA VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN THE ARMY
CHARACTERISTICS PERSONAL SUPPORT
PERFECT.
MIKE MONEY GONNA BE HALF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MA'AM PLEASE SUBMIT A
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT.
MCKINLEY THOMPSON MARLEY ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY VENTURA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THINKING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC LIKE TO TEST
CLIENTS FOR THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE HE REMEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF WHISTLER.
OPINION ON THE AUTHORS BILL.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
COMING KALRA.
THANK GOODNESS YOU'RE NOT USING
CALABAR SCREEN.
WELL SAID.
IT IS THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
OFFER.
CENTER WHICH LIKE CLOSE --
I DON'T HAVE A CAR IN TWO HOURS --
TWENTY TWO USE PUBLIC TRANSIT --
URGENT I'D VOTE FOR STUDENTS
LIKE I USED TO BE AT THE
UNIVERSITY ASSEMBLY STATE.
THERE CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER OF FOR BRINGS BILL FOR
TODAY.
MAKING LC TOP MORE FLEXIBLE WILL
HELP ACHIEVE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM. TO INCREASE MODE
SHIFTED REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES
ALLOW TRANSIT AGENCIES TO FIND
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM SYSTEMS WIDE.
SUCH AS A STE STUDENT TRANSIT
PASSES WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
ATTRACTING NEW AND HOPEFULLY
LIFETIME WRITERS OF THE VOTING
ON THE GOAL WE HAVE.
PUTTING AYE ON THE BILL WE GET A
QUORUM.
AND US WITH THAT.
WE SHOULD SEE.
THREE IF ONE SHORT.
SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
S. B..
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS SO
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO CALM SP LIVES
OF THE TWO IT PUTS A HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY ON PAR WITH THE
STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE IN
CHARGE OF STRUCTURING MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PRODDED HER FROM
INTERRUPT YOU SO YOU GET A
QUORUM REAL.
QUICK AND WE GOT [inaudible]
THAT'S PLEASE CULTURAL
[inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
HERE FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU.
DALY HERE FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
HARPER [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
NUYS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM --
THEY'RE BUILT PLEASE CONTINUE
SORRY FOR THE INTERRUPTION LOVES --
WHAT -- THIS
DOES IS SIMILAR TO OTHER --
STATE AGENCIES --
AFFORDS THE AUTHORITY THAT WITH
THE SAME RIGHT AWAY ACQUISITION
TOOLS.
THAT REMOVE THE DUPLICATIVE
REQUIREMENTS AND STREAMLINES
OTHER PROCESS.
THAT WILL ONLY SAVE THE THE
STATE BOTH TIME AND MONEY --
THE PROPERTY ACQUISITION DELAYS
SO OF THE AUTHORITY HAVE BEEN
WIDELY REPORTED --
AUTHORITIES BUSINESS PLAN NOTES
AND LESSONS LEARNED SECTION.
THEY HAD THE AUTHORITY --
PLANS ON TAKING NUMBER STEPS TO
REMEDY THE FUTURE DELAYS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP THE ACHIEVE
THE GOAL IN ALLOWING MORE
STREAMLINED PROCESS.
THIS CONSISTENT WITH THE
AUTHORITY OF OTHER STATE
AGENCIES.
OF IT DOES NOT REMOVE THE
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS ARE OR ERROR
PROVIDE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY WITH ANY AUTHORITY
THAT GOES BEYOND.
PROVIDED OTHER STATE AGENCIES.
IN FACT THE BILL WILL CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THE INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT.
OF THEY THIRTY A THROUGH THE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD'S APPROVAL.
OF THE RESOLUTIONS OF NECESSITY.
AND I'LL SAY THE STATE TIME AND
MONEY AYE URGENT AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
TRINITY RIVER SIMPLY SAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KEEP DOWN HERE
ON BEHALF THE ASSOCIATION FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED TRAINS OF
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE.
INVOLVED IN THIS PROGRAM SINCE
ITS INCEPTION IN WHAT I WOULD
TELL YOU IS THAT THIS IS THE
EXACT TYPE A BILL.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHERS
IN THIS BY PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY TO LEARN FROM THE
PROCESS THAT THEY'VE HAD IN THE
PAST TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT
PROCESS OF THE CAN DO IN A MORE
STREAMLINED FASHION DELIVER THE
PROGRAM MORE EFFICIENTLY.
THIS IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT
PROCESS FOR THOSE PROPERTY
OWNERS THAT ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF NEGOTIATING AND TALKING WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL ABOUT THEIR
PROPERTY AND HOW THOSE
ACQUISITIONS MOVE FOR ITS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO FOR THOSE
PROPERTY OWNERS DIVIDE THEM A
STREAMLINED OPPORTUNITY.
TO ADJUDICATE THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES A PROVIDES THE
AUTHORITY HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY WITH THE ABILITY. TO
INTERACT ON BEHALF OF THEMSELVES
AND REPRESENT THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD ARGUE AGAIN THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS.
HAS DIRECTED THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY TO DO AND IS EXACTLY
THE TYPE OF BILL THAT WE NEED I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLICLY
TESTIFY PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THERE.
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT.
THEN CHILDREN WITHOUT A TIE
COOLEY COOPER HAS TRANSIT CHAIR
MEMBERS OF IDEAS ON HOW THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OFTEN SUPPORT.
FIXER ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THANK TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HE MEMBERS OF PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION TO VOICE THEIR
OPINION ON THE BILL.
THE QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR.
CENTER WHICH LIKE CLOTHES ARJUN
I'VE ON THIS MISSION.
THEY SENATOR BILL OBVIOUS WHERE
YOUR BILL TODAY.
THE RIGHT AWAY PROCESS TO
CONTINUES TO BE A TOP RISK --
FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
I ACTUALLY SURPLUS A PUBLIC
WORKS BOARD AND SEEN HOW
DESPERATELY NEEDED THIS IS --
THIS BILL IS TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THEM PROTECT NOT ONLY THE
LANDOWNER BUT ALSO THE RISK HIGH
SPEED RAIL TAKES.
IT HAS CONTRIBUTED TO A TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
COST OVERRUNS INSIGNIFICANCE
INSIGNIFICANT SCHEDULED LIFE AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ALONG.
I BRING YOU THIRTY ONE OF THE
RIGHT OF WAY PROCESS CALTRANS
ANOTHER STATE AGENCIES USE HELP
MITIGATE THIS RISK.
AND HOWEVER I REMAIN COMMITTED
TO STRINGENT OVERSIGHT.
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS IS WHY ADDED A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL SO
MEMBERS CAN CONTINUE TO ASSESS
THE PROGRESS OF THE PROJECT IN A
PUBLIC FORUM WAS STAKEHOLDER
INPUT.
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THIS WILL SAVE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS GOING
FORWARD OF THE VOTING ANY BILL
TODAY'S --
THAT SECRETARY PLEASE KALRA. ONE
OF THE MACHINE.
I HAD THE I HEAR CURRY AND THEN --
FRIEDMAN SO MEMBER FREEMAN
SECOND PLACE CULTURAL.
THE MOTION HAS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER A RANGER I
FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
HARPER.
HARPER NOW MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I THREE THAT'S FOURTH
WE WILL LEAVE ROLLED OPEN TRAPS
IN MEMBERS THANK YOU.
CENTER WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
YEAH.
OF GOING TO THE NEXT ONE IF I
CAN MISTER CHAIRMAN IT IS IT IS
OUR PLEASURE. SIXTY TWO TWELVE
SIXTY TWO MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THE THIS BILL S. B. --
TWELVE SIXTY TWO THIS IS
INEFFICIENCY MEASURE ASSISTING
CALTRANS AND STRETCHING THE
RECENT --
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THE LEGISLATURE MADE IN THE LAST
YEAR'S SP.
ONE THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE
CALTRANS WITH THE PERMANENT
AUTHORITY PERMANENT AUTHORITY.
TO UTILIZE THE CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER GENERAL CONTRACTOR
PROJECT DELIVERY MASSIVE --
METHOD --
THIS IS RICHER REFERRED TO S.
CMG SEE --
WHICH TO OF THROUGH THE
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZE PILOT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED HIS --
IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE PROJECT
DELIVERY TOOLBOX GIVING THE
STATE MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY. TO
ACHIEVE SAVINGS ON SOUTHERN CAL
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
NOW WITH LAST YEAR'S HISTORICAL
INVESTMENT TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING.
I BELIEVE WE OUGHT TO
CALIFORNIA'S CONTENT WE LOOK AT
WAYS MORE EFFICIENTLY INVEST IN
THE TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS.
THIS TOOL WILL DECREASE PROJECT
COSTS ON THE MOST COMPLEX OF
PROJECTS BY BETTER FOR
IDENTIFICATION.
MITIGATION ELIMINATION RESTS
INCREASED.
INNOVATIVE CONSTRUCTION AND
STAGING.
AND REDUCE CLAIMS AND CHANGE
ORDERS AND HIGHER QUALITY PLANTS.
WITH IMPROVED --
CONSTRUCT ABILITY BY THE
ANTICIPATING AND PREEMPTING
PROBLEMS.
THIS APPROACH WILL SAVE THE
STAPLE TIME AND MONEY.
THE BILL IS A SIMPLE STEP.
WE CAN TAKE TO ENSURE.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
TAKING THE FULL ADVANTAGE.
OF THE PROVEN BEST PRACTICES TO
KEEP FAITH WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS.
THE IT WITH THE MOST EFFICIENT
EXPAND SURE.
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS POSSIBLE --
WITHOUT LIGHTS A REQUEST OF AND
I VOTE TODAY.
AND WE HAVE A WITNESSES BUT CHAO
TURN OVER THE MOVE THE BILL.
USAGE MEMORY REPRESENT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
MELANIE PAN WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO SENATOR PELL FOR
CARRYING THIS MEASURE.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT FOR
CALTRANS TO CHIEF OF THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN EFFICIENCIES
AS REQUIRED BY ASKING.
ONE THIS DESPITE THIS SOUNDS
HE'S ME THIS PROJECT DELIVERY
METHOD.
AND ALLOWS FOR EARLY
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER COMING ON
DURING THE DESIGN PHASE OF THE
PROJECT.
THIS ALLOWS FOR BETTER RISK
ASSESSMENT AND MANAGEMENT BETTER
QUALITY PLANS.
AND ULTIMATELY DURING THE
CONSTRUCTION I REGIS CONTRACT
CHANGE ORDERS.
THIS WILL HELP CALTRANS
DELIBERATE PROJECTS QUICKER AND
SAVE MONEY ULTIMATELY.
THE SAVINGS CAN THEN BE USED ON
OTHER PART TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THIS ISSUE OF THE RIVER
SEPARATES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN PERSPECTIVES JOYFUL
BEHIND THEM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I'M
HERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE TO TWO BECAUSE THIS BILL
PROVIDES CALTRANS THE ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY WHEN THE LIVING
PROJECTS.
THE COMMISSION BELIEVES THAT THE
SEEM CHEESY APPROACH COULD LEAD
TO A LESS EXPENSIVE AND MORE
EXPEDIENT WE LOOK AT PROJECTS
GETS ALLOWS THE AGENCY TO ENGAGE
WITH OUR CONSTRUCTION EXPERT.
EARLY IN THE DESIGN PROCESS TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE THAT CITING
TO RESOLVE ANY ISSUES BEFORE
DESIGNS [inaudible]
COMPLETED.
THE COMMISSION COMMEND SENATOR
HEALTH LEADERSHIP AND MOVING A
POLICY TO OFFERS FLEXIBILITY
CONTRACT FOR PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES WHILE FOSTERING
INNOVATION.
IN PROJECT DELIVERY WE BELIEVE
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO IDENTIFY
AND IMPLEMENT PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES AND IMPROVE PROJECT
DELIVERY TO ENSURE THE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS.
ARE USED WISELYWE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR COMMITTEE.
OF SB.
TWELVE SIXTY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WHO REPRESENT PLEASE.
ACCOUNT MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TIM CHIANG FOR
THE AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE
DO SUPPORT USING OUR
TRANSPORTATION REVENUES
SUFFICIENTLY.
MCKINLEY THOMPSON MARLEY ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THINKING.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO LIKED TESTIFIES FOR THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO VOICE HER OPINION
OF THE AUTHOR STILL.
SEEM NOT ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE SEEING NONE
SENATOR WAS LIKE CLOTHES.
OF THANK YOU ARE I THINK GO
[inaudible]
AGAIN.
FOLLOWING UP WITH SP --
ONE WE MUST ACTORS PROPER
STEWARDS ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA'S
THE TOOLS TO DELIVER PROJECTS
SUFFICIENTLY.
THIS MAKES GOOD SENSE TO TO
UTILIZE EVERY AVAILABLE TOOL TO
CUT COSTS AND EXPEDITE A
PROJECTS --
THIS WILL PROVIDE CALTRANS WITH
AN IMPORTANT TOOL AND NOW I US
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR --
FOR PICKING UP THIS IMPORTANT
BILL FROM SENATOR NEWMAN AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET
CALTRANS AS MANY TOOLS.
AS POSSIBLE DELIVER PROJECTS OF
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
AND THEIR FORUMS AS A FORMER
CONTRACTOR ALSO SUPPORTING OUR
BILL.
A WE HAVE A FIRST BY A YEAR AND
YOUR CARE CURRY AND THE SECOND
AYE FRIEDMAN --
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
ODOM.
IT HAS SEVERAL THE WITH THE ROLE
OPEN FRETS A MEMBERS.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONES S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CENTER --
THIS BILL OF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
EXTENSIVE SUNSET.
FURTHER --
DEPARTMENT VOTER VEHICLES
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE PILOT
PROGRAM.
BY ONE YEAR.
FROM.
TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
ORIGINALLY THE PILOT PROGRAM WAS
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A THOUSAND
PLATES BUT THEY'VE ONLY MANAGED
TO SO FORGET TO FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY SO THEY NEED A YEAR AND A
COMPLETE THE PILOT PROGRAM.
GET THE FULL OF NUMBER AND NOT
COMPLETE APPLIED A PROGRAM.
AND THEN --
WE'LL SEE THE RESULTS AND SEE
THAT -- THE
GOOD THING ABOUT THING ARE CHEN
AYE VOTE ON THIS SO WE CAN NOT
COMPLETE OUR PILOT PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
WAS A CONSTITUENT WHO REPRESENT
THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SARAH
JOHNSON WITH CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES BEING OFF A HALF OF
JIM LINKS --
AGAIN THIS BILL SIMPLY TO EXTEND
THE PILOT PROGRAM FROM.
JANUARY FIRST WE NINETEEN UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND NOTHING ABOUT THE PILOT WILL
CHANGE FROM THE BILL BEING
PASSED TODAY EXCEPT FOR THIS ON
SUNDAY.
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU CRUCIFIXION
[inaudible]
REFERENCE WAS [inaudible]
IT.
POSITIONING WE REPRESENT PLEASE
CHRIS RESUME HAVE THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY SUPPORT
AUTHORS BILL TEST BY AN
OPPOSITIONAL RESEARCH PAYING ON
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
CENTER.
THAT'S ALL WE NEED NO EXCUSE ME.
OF ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
SORRY. FOR THE RUSSIA SO WE NEED
TO DO SOME OF THESE PILOTS A DMB --
COURAGE INEFFICIENCY THERE.
ARE CHEN AYE VOTE.
THE CENTER OF WITHOUT OF AGES
SUPPORTING A BILL.
A WE HAVE A FIRST BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAKER SECOND BY SOME
REMEMBER FONG.
ANSWERED YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU.
DALY.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS MEDINA
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THERE IT SIX WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
THAT WRAPS MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR [inaudible]
WE DID.
HUGS TO THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS WILL REMEMBER
[inaudible]
REALLY [inaudible]
THREE SENATE PORTANTINO.
WE'VE S. B. FILE ITEM NINETEEN
S. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY PLEASE I PRESENT
WE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M PRESENTING
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY I WANNA I
THANK THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF.
SUBMIT SOME AMENDMENTS WHICH I
BELIEVE WHEN IN ITS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS AND THERE BUT THEY
WERE OF MOSTLY DUE TO THE DUE
DILIGENCE OF YOUR STAFF SO THANK
YOU TAKE --
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW A PERSON
WITH A DRIVER'S LICENSE FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY TO BE EXEMPT
FROM TAKING THE BEHIND THE WHEEL
EXEMPTION.
WHEN APPLYING FOR CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE?
WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY COMES TO
CALIFORNIA WITH PROPER
DOCUMENTATION --
INCLUDING A DRIVER'S LICENSE
HERE SHE HAS TO GET EITHER A
CALIFORNIA ID FOR A CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE AS SOON AS THE
RESIDENTS HE IS DECLARED.
OF THE PROCESS IN SELF CAN BE
EXTREMELY ONEROUS THIS BILL TAKE
SEVERAL STEPS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
WHILE ALLOWING FOREIGN NATIONALS
TO HAVE THE DRIVING PORTION OF
DMV'S EXAM WAVED THEY MUST STILL
PASS THE WRITTEN EXAM AND TAKE
THE VISUAL AND HEARING
EXAMINATION THESE ARE THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON HOW TO
STATE DRIVERS TO ESTABLISH
RESIDENCY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND APPLY FOR CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE FURTHER A
FOREIGN COUNTRIES RESIDENTS WILL
ONLY BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
DRIVING DAMNATION WAIVED IF THE
AND THE HAS MADE A FINDING.
THAT THAT FOREIGN COUNTRY.
DRIVING EXAM IS SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR TO OURS --
SO BASICALLY THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
SIMILAR PROGRAM AS OURS AND THAT
HAS TO BE VERIFIED --
ALSO COUNTRY HAS A SIGN
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHAT THEY WILL PROVIDE THE SAME
TREATMENT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
LICENSEES IN THEIR TERRITORIES.
IF THE DMV HAS VERIFIED THAT A
FOREIGN NATION HAS A STAT
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR BEHIND THE
WHEEL EXAMINATION.
AN AMMO YOU HAS BEEN SIGNED DMB
MUST THEN VERIFY THAT THERE ARE
NO STOPS HOLDS OR OTHER
IMPEDIMENTS. TO THE ISSUANCE OF
AN APPLICANT'S EXISTING LICENSE
BEFORE CAN BE CAN WAIVE THE
BEHIND THE WHEEL.
DMV MUST ALSO RECEIVE A COPY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS DRIVING RECORD
FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
TRANSLATED INTO ENGLISH AND A
COPY OF HIS OR HER LICENSE
TRANSLATED INTO ENGLISH.
AND BOTH MUST BE NOTARIZED BY
THE COUNCIL WOULD GENERAL'S
OFFICE OF THE COUNTRY OF ORIGIN
IN CALIFORNIA.
BY HAVING FIVE YEARS WORTH OF
DRIVING HE WILL BE ABLE TO
ASSESS ANY EQUIVALENT NEGLIGENT
OPERATOR POINTS ONTO THAT
INDIVIDUALS LICENSE.
AS IF THEY HAD COMMITTED THE
DRIVING OFFENSE IN CALIFORNIA.
DMV ALSO DOES THIS FOR DRIVERS
FROM OTHER STATES WHO HAVE
EXCHANGE OUR LICENSE FOR
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE IN
ADDITION.
WHILE.
THE DRIVER FROM A FOREIGN NATION
CAN SUMMIT COMMERCIAL OR NON
COMMERCIAL CLASS A. B. OR C.
LICENSES TABLER EXAMINATION WAIT
THEY WILL ONLY BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE A NONCOMMERCIAL CLASS C.
LICENSE.
FINALLY THE LICENSE WILL HAVE TO
STE THE LICENSEE WILL AFTER
DRIVER'S LICENSE TO THE DMV. FOR
DESTRUCTION --
FOR EXAMPLE --
KOREA HAS NEGOTIATED TWENTY
THREE OF THESE AMMO USE WITH
OTHER STATES INCLUDING ARIZONA
AND TWENTY TWO OTHER STATES THIS
IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT.
WHAT THE COMMITTEE DOES IS MADE
THIS EVEN TO APPLY TO ALL
COUNTRIES WHICH I APPRECIATE OUT
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL I HAVE LONG IN SONG WHO
IS THE DEPUTY COUNSEL GENERAL?
FROM THE COUNCIL OF OF OF
REPUBLIKA KOREAN LOS ANGELES --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THOSE
SOMEBODY MEMBERS CLIFTON ON
BEHALF OF THE KOREAN GOVERNMENT
AND COULD HAVE PEOPLE I THINK
IT'S SO MUCH FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK ABOUT HOW
THIS TO BE SICK.
PROCOL DRIVER'S LICENSE PROGRAM
WILL BENEFIT.
BOTH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTH KOREA AND OTHER COUNTRIES
IN THE WORLD.
WHEN IT COMES TO KOREA
CALIFORNIA RELATIONS SOUTH KOREA
IS THE THIRD LARGEST TRADE
BUTTON TO STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
WITH OVER ONE HUNDRED NINETY
BILLION DOLLARS INVITED FOR
TRADE.
AND THEY INVESTMENT FROM KOREA
TO CALIFORNIA IS TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS CREATURE EVER
CREATED TENS OF THOUSAND JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND THREE ACCORDING TO
RECENT DATA SEVERAL UNDER THE
FIFTY THOUSAND KOREANS AND
KOREAN AMERICANS ARE LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND TEN THOUSAND CONTESTED
UNTESTED HERE TO STUDY.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THAT
BEATS PROCOL DRIVERS LICENSE
PROGRAM.
WILL GREATLY BENEFIT BOTH
FOREIGN COUNTRIES TO INCLUDING
SOUTH KOREA AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
FIRST.
GIVEN THAT A DRIVER'S LICENSE IS
THE FIRST THING TO DO FOR
SETTLING DOWN.
AS THE STATE REGION DOES THIS
PROGRAM WILL MAKE TO SETTLE DOWN
PROCESS EASIER AND FASTER.
BY REDUCING TESTING BE QUIET.
BUT THOSE WHO HAVE BADLY DRIVERS
LICENSE FROM KOREA ADVICE WAS UP
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AT THE SAME TIME --
DIFFICULTLY DOT RECIPROCAL
PROGRAM ALSO BE JUST TIME AND
COST FOR THE DMV FIELD OFFICERS.
BECAUSE PEOPLE BROUGHT WITH BUT
IT DRIVE RIGHT SINCE FROM SOUTH
KOREA DON'T HAVE.
TO GO TO ALL OF THE LICENSING
PROCESS THIRDLY GIFTS RECIPROCAL
PROGRAM.
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT SIGN OF
CALIFORNIA'S OPENNESS AND
FRIENDSHIP WITH SOUTH KOREA AND
THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
AND YOU DO PROMOTE TRADE AND
INVESTMENT BY CREATING BEGINS
FRIENDLY ENVIRONMENT.
IN CONGRESS AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS PROGRAM.
S. MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL TO KOREA
AND OTHER FORTY COUNTRIES AND
CALIFORNIA AND YOU DID YOU SPEND
THAT.
OF FRIENDSHIP AND COOPERATION
[inaudible]
I YES.
SO I HOPE THAT DO SO STATE ALL
CALIFORNIA WITH JOINT.
THE OTHER TEN YOU TOOK THE STAGE
INCLUDING.
I JOIN IN WASHINGTON.
AND THAT ALREADY HAVE SIMILARLY
TO PRICKLE AGREEMENT WITH KOREA
AS WITH ONE HUNDRED SUCH ONE
COUNTRIES OR OF THE COUNTRY.
UP TO WHAT THEY COULDN'T.
THANK YOU --
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
STILL LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY OF ANY MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION VOICE OUR OPINION OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER.
HARPER LANDESMAN IS BAKER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SHARE.
SO I UNDERSTAND THIS BILL IS NOT
JUST ABOUT REPUBLICAN CAREER
THIS THREAD GOT DOWN ON ON
NATIONS THAT MAY FIT THE
CRITERIA.
ON THE BIGGEST CONCERN THAT I
HAVE ABOUT THE BILL HOWEVER I IS
ABOUT THE ELIMINATION OF THE
PROOF OF INSURANCE.
I RIVER OF WALKING BY WATCHING
THE DEBATE ABOUT SIXTY BY AB
SIXTY AND IN THAT DEBATE ABOUT
DRIVERS LICENSES FOR ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND SUCH A BIG PART OF
THE QUESTION --
WAS ABOUT --
MAKING SURE THAT DE WE GOT
UNINSURED DRIVERS OFF THE ROAD
MAKING SURE THE PEOPLE ARE
QUALIFY PICTURES.
SO IF YOU CAN KIND OF CLARIFY
THE THIS ISSUE HERE ABOUT THE
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS OFF ON
THIS IN OUR WE ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE POTENTIALLY
ALLOWING --
UNINSURED DRIVERS ON THE ROAD NO
THERE'S NO INTENTION TO ALLOW
UNINSURED DRIVERS TO DRIVE ON
THE ROADS.
ACTORS THAT'S SO.
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CLARIFICATION.
SIMILARLY BAKER.
THANK YOU AND THEM THANK YOU.
FOR OF COMING AND TESTIFYING
FIRST PLACE I WENT AWAY FROM I
WAS A KID WAS.
TO GRIP SOUTH KOREA SO I'M AND
I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE THE
CONNECTION YOU'RE TRYING.
TO READ SHARE MY CONCERN IS YOU
KNOW MY KIDS ARE GONNA BE ON THE
ROAD AND ABOUT A YEAR AND I'M A
LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT THAT I I AM
STEPS MUST BE EXCITED THAT THEY
WILL DRIVE THEMSELVES PLACES BUT
THEY HAVE TO TAKE THE TEST IN
PART OF THE PURPOSE.
OF IT OF THE DRIVING TASK.
AT THE WRITTEN OR WAVING.
IS TO I THINK TO SEE HOW THEY
WILL OPERATE UNDER REAL
CIRCUMSTANCES IN REAL PRESSURE --
REALIZING THAT THERE ARE SOME
COUNTRIES THAT DON'T DRIVE ON
THE SAME SIDE OF THE ROAD THAT
WE DO THAT DON'T HAVE THE SAME
RULES THREE TO MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THIS.
LOOKS TO SEE IF THE TEST IS
COMPARABLE.
BUT NOT THE NECESSARILY THE SAME
ACTUAL RULES OF THE OTHER
COUNTRY --
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT BECAUSE I I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHY WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING THE SAME RULES BE
FOLLOWED.
AND AND HOW I WOULD GET OVER THE
CONCERN THAT SOMEONE WILL BE ON
THE ROAD THE SAME ROAD THAT MY
KIDS ARE GOING TO BE ON MY
CONSTITUENTS.
WHO HAS NOT TAKEN A REAL LIFE
TEST HERE UNDER OUR RULES AND
BILL TRAFFIC CONDITIONS?
AND I WOULD SAY TWO THINGS
NUMBER ONE THAT'S NO DIFFERENT
THAN THE PERSON FROM KANSAS.
OR FLORIDA OR SOUTH DAKOTA WHEN
THEY COME HERE IT'S EXACTLY THE
SAME THAT WE TREAT THAT WE WOULD
BE TREATING THEM --
THIS MEANS THAT THE COUNTRY HAS
HAVE A VERIFIED BEHIND THE WHEEL
PROGRAM SIMILAR TO OURS --
OTHER STATES HAVE DIFFERENT
DRIVING RULES THOSE PEOPLE SOFT
TAKE THE WRITTEN TEST. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS.
SAME WOULD APPLY HERE --
THESE FOLKS FROM WHATEVER
COUNTRY THAT MEETS THE CRITERIA
WOULD STILL HAVE TO TAKE THE
WRITTEN TEST SO FOR EXAMPLE NOT
EVERY STATE HAS RIGHT TURN ON
RED --
DIFFERENT STATES HAVE DIFFERENT
DRIVING LAWS WE DON'T WE DON'T
LEVEL THIS ANY DIFFERENTLY IF
YOU WERE FROM NEBRASKA.
OR SOUTH DAKOTA SO WHICH
TREATING THESE FOLKS EXACTLY THE
SAME WAY.
I APPRECIATE THAT I I DO SEE A
DIFFERENCE WE HAVE AT LEAST HAVE
A UNIFORMITY.
OF SIGNAGE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GO
OVER TO EUROPE YOU COVERAGE PAN
YOU COULD EITHER COUNTRIES THE
SCIENCE THE THE WAY THEY MARK
THEIR LINES ON THE STREETS ARE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT AND AGAIN
THERE MAY BE DRIVING ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE ROAD --
AND INTESTINE NOT THAT.
BETWEEN ARE EVERYWHERE ELSE IN
THE FIFTY STATES AND AND WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES.
WHICH CONCERNS ME AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN CAN ADDRESS JUST
WHAT.
ARE MAYBE THAT WAS THAT THE
EFFORT BUT WHAT.
WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE SEE UNDER
REAL CIRCUMSTANCES THAT SOMEONE
IN THE REAL FIELD IN OUR AREA IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE
SAFELY ON THE ROADS AND THAT'S
WHERE THE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
PROGRAM COMES INTO EFFECT --
D. M. V. WILL BE MAKING SURE
THAT WHATEVER COUNTRIES APPLYING
FOR THIS MEETS OUR STANDARDS.
THAT'S THE SAFEGUARD THEY HAVE
TO MEET OUR STATE I PERSONALLY
SPOKE IN THE EXAMPLE OF KOREA
MET WITH THEIR TRAFFIC FOLKS
PERSONALLY AND TALKED ABOUT.
HOW THEY DO IT AND IT IS MODELED
ON OUR PROGRAM SO?
THAT'S THE SAFEGUARD HERE IS
THEY HAVE TO BE SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR WITH CALIFORNIA DOES --
TO GET THIS BENEFIT IF THEY
DON'T AND IF THEY DON'T PROVIDE
ALL OF THE DOCUMENTATION OF THEY
DON'T.
PROVIDE THEIR DRIVING RECORDS IF
THEY DON'T PROVIDE WHICH
INCLUDES THEIR ANY POINTS THAT
WOULD BE APPLICABLE --
SO I THINK THE CRITERIA IS
PRETTY STRONG AND STRINGENT AND
SORT OF FOLLOWS OF LOGICAL.
A ASSUMPTIONS --
AND AGAIN IT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN.
YOU KNOW NEBRASKA OR FLORIDA.
AMANDA STILL THINK I GUESS IT IS
DIFFERENT IN THE SENSE THAT YOU
MAY HAVE COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
VERY DIFFERENT FOUND.
AND SIGNAGE RULES BUT THAT MAY
JUST BE -- A
FAIR POINT IF OF LOOKING AT IT
DIFFERENTLY.
AND THEN THAT IF YOU CAN ALSO IT
CLARIFIER WHY WE ARE LOOKING AT
MAKING SURE THAT IF THERE LAWS
AND TESTING IS THE SAME BUT THE
THEIR THEIR TEST PROCEDURES.
AND NOT THEIR ACTUAL RULES OF
THE ROAD --
Y. THAT TREATING THOSE TWO
DIFFERENTLY UNDER YOUR BILL
BECAUSE I THINK THE POINT IS
THAT NOT EVERY COUNTRY NOT EVERY
STATE HAS EXACTLY THE SAME RULES
OF THE ROAD THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER THESE ARE COMPETENT.
SAFE DRIVERS VERIFIED BY FIVE
YEARS OF DRIVING HISTORY.
VERIFIED BY THE TRAINING. TO A
PROGRAM THAT'S COMPARABLE TO
OURS.
I MEAN YOU NEVER GONNA HAVE AN
EXACT MATCH BUT THIS.
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIALLY SAID THIS
PROVIDES CONTROLS AND THAT WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE CAME UP
WITH WITH THAT DEFINITION. TO
APPLY EVENLY THERE ARE GONNA BE
COUNTRIES THAT JUST CANNOT APPLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
MEET THOSE STANDARDS.
THAT'S THEIR PROBLEM NOT OURS
BUT FOR THE COUNTRIES THAT MEET
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS.
AND SUPPLY ALL OF THIS
DOCUMENTATION FOR CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS WHEN YOU KNOW THE
EIGHTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND HAS --
OF POPULATION OF OF FOREIGN
NATIONALS AND A MYRIAD OF
BUSINESSES THIS IS A WAY TO
FACILITATE SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
TRADE IN FRIENDSHIP AND AN
ESPRIT DE CORPS WITH THESE
COUNTRIES THAT DO BUSINESS WITH
US.
IN A WAY THAT I THINK HAS A
APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
VICE CHAIR FOLK.
I JUST REAL QUICK AB IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING UNDER EXISTING LAW
THE EXISTING SO AND THAT THE DMB
VERIFIES --
DRIVERS PROOF OF INSURANCE --
BEFORE MISSION THE DRIVING TEST
SO IF THE IF THE DRIVING TEST IS
WAIVED WHERE IN THE PROCESS TO
SOMEONE PROVE INSURANCE.
WE CAN CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S NO INTENTION TO HAVE ANY
INSURANCE BREAKS BE.
HAPPENED I MEAN THAT'S YOU KNOW
IF WE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT
LANGUAGE I'M HAPPY TO WORK ON
THAT AS THIS BILL PROGRESSES I
MEAN I IT'S NOT.
WE DON'T SEE THAT AS AN ISSUE.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T SEE THAT AS A
AS A BARRIER NOT TO CLEAR UP IF
IT'S NOT CLEAR ENOUGH IN THE
LEGISLATION I THINK THAT'S THE
CONCERN THAT I THINK IS RIGHT
WAS ABILITY TO DO THAT FUNDS.
YEAH.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO ISSUES
WITH AND WITH HAVING INSURANCE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL --
CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WELL WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL.
AND TO GIVE THE DMV VIA ABILITY
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION OF
FOREIGN NATIONS.
DRIVING'S AMINATION IS
COMPATIBLE TO TO OUR OWN BEFORE
WAVING THE EXAM.
AND AGAIN BEING ABLE TO ADD
OTHER COUNTRIES JUST IT SEEMED
RIGHT.
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD DO
EXTEND THE FRIENDSHIP AND THE
ABILITY.
TO TO FROM OF COMMERCE IN
CALIFORNIA --
SO BE SPORTING A BILL TODAY
AMOUNT SECRETARY CULTURAL.
HOPE BETTER FIRST FRIEDMAN A
SECOND BERMAN WAS FOR US FOR THE
MOTION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BAKER.
BAKER NO BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THAT IS FIVE TO TO LEAVE THE
ROLE BUT PERHAPS A MEMBERS.
NEXT UP IS A CENTER LARA.
THERE BE FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
S. B. NINE FIFTY SEVEN GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
AS OTHER THAN EVER A PONTIAC
ESTABLISHES --
A PATHWAY FOR CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS THAT MAKE FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS A YEAR
TO APPLY FOR A GREEN STICKER CAR
WHEN THEY PURCHASE A USED. ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE EXISTING LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW THE SECOND
STICKER FOUR ZERO EMISSION CARS
WHICH PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED ONE
THIS BASICALLY ELIMINATES A USED.
THAT OPTION IT IS UNFAIR FOR OUR
CLEAN TECHNOLOGY INITIATIVES --
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERY CALIFORNIAN --
WHEN THE UC STUDY THIS ISSUE THE
H. OF THE STICKER WAS THE NUMBER
ONE REASON FOR MORE THAN HALF OF
THE PEOPLE WHO BOUGHT A NEW
CLEAN VEHICLE?
BUT IF YOU CAN ONLY GET THIS
INCENTIVE WHAT THE NEW EXPENSIVE
ELECTRIC CAR THAT HOW CAN LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA'S EVER HAVE
ACCESS.
I KNOW MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE A
CONCERNS ABOUT CONGESTION THE H.
WILL BE LAID TONIGHT DIFF
DEFINITELY RESPECT --
THAT ISSUE THAT IS WHY WE WE
TOOK ON AMENDMENT TO CREATE --
TO DO A SUNSET ON THE IS ON THE
BILL TO ALLOW US TO STUDY THE
ISSUE -- IF
THIS BILL WERE TO MOVE FORWARD
SURE THAT --
WHERE ALLOWING A MARKET TO BE
ABLE OF GOING TO EXISTENCE WITH
THE USE THAT VEHICLE TO ALLOW?
OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE TICKERS AS
WELL AND SO THE SUNSET --
THAT WE TOOK IN THE PLACENTA
TRANSPORTATION ALLOWS US FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE TO LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE AND HAS A TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO ALLOW US TO
ASSESS THE IMPACT.
OF THE PROGRAM ON THE ADOPTION
OF ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
THE IMPACT ON THE HOV LANES I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
OF THE ISSUE THIS IS WHY --
AGAIN WE TRY TO BRING --
SOME SORT OF BALANCE AND GET
THIS OUR SUNSET IN PLACE SO WE
CAN STUDY THE ISSUE AT LEAST AS
WE WILL FORWARD TO LOOK FORWARD
ARE IN TERMS OF THE EACH OF THE
STICKERS ON THE IMPACTS ON EACH
WILL BE LANES.
BUT WE REALLY WANT UP --
DO SOMETHING FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES CREATE A MARKET FOR
OUR USED ZAPS THAT ARE NOW
COMING IN MARKET SO YOU KNOW
WE'RE TRYING.
TO FIND A PROBLEM BY SPREAD DO
UNDERSTAND AND RESPECT YOUR YOUR
POSITION ON THE ISSUE.
SENATOR I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
SOME WHAT IS.
JUST FIND SUPPORT PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND WE REPRESENT
PLEASE PART JULIE MALINOWSKI BOB
HAVE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION I HAVE
TO ADDITIONAL POINTS TO MAKE
ABOUT WHY THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT.
I WOULD START WITH THIS BODY
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY HAS A VERY
LONG AND STRONG HISTORY OF
MAKING SURE THAT OUR LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS IN OUR
CLIMATE OF PROGRAMS.
A ARE ARE THERE ALSO FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA'S IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LONG
HISTORY THIS BILL JUST SIMPLY
BUILT ON THAT REPUTATION THIS
BODY HAS TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
THE SECOND POINT IS IS THAT
FRANKLY THE MORE PEOPLE WHO CAN
DRIVE THESE CARS THAT FASTER WE
ARE TO GET TO THAT PENETRATION
THAT PENETRATION LEVELS THAT WE
WE NEED TO SEE --
AND SO.
YOU KNOW IF WE'RE LEAVING OUT
LOW INCOME BECAUSE LEAVING OUT A
HUGE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO WHO
NEED TO GET EDUCATED ABOUT THIS
TO HELP US WITH OUR OUR CLIMB IN
OUR CLEAN AIR GOALS.
US SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND HE
RIPS AND POPS KERN AUGUSTINE
WITH THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL FOR MANY OF THE
REASONS THE SENATOR OUTLINED WE
DO THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY. TO LET FOLKS WHO DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS --
TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO HOV LANES --
RIGHT NOW TO DO THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF BARRIERS TO GETTING
WARMER THESE VEHICLES ON WE SEE
THIS IS ONE WAY TO REDUCING IT.
AT A NO COST OF THE STATE WAY WE
DO SHARE --
CONCERNS ABOUT --
ANY HOV IMPACT I THINK WE THINK
THE CURRENT LAW WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AND ALSO THE
REDUCTION OF AGE OF THE STICKERS
THAT WILL OCCUR AT THE END OF
THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
WITH THE OLD PROGRAM THE NEW
PROGRAM STARTING THERE WILL BE A
LOT LESS --
VEHICLES IMPACTING THE LANES AND
THAT TO WHILE A VALID CONCERN I
THINK IS GOING TO BE ADDRESSED
BY GET BY.
CURRENT LAW AND THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC STILL LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO VOICE OUR OPINION.
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS MISTER
BERMAN --
MISS BERMAN TO SECOND NAY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MISTER --
SETTLER WAS LIKE CLOSE I JUST
STRUCK WE ASK FOR A VOTE THANK
YOU.
SENATOR LARA UNFORTUNATELY.
AS YOU KNOW I CAN'T SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY ON I UNDERSTAND AND I
WISH THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY.
A INCENTIVIZE IN REVERSE OF WHAT
WE DO WITH THE THESE ARE THE
EFFECTS OF THE RICH.
GET THE THE THINGS CENTERS IN.
THE LEAVE THE INDIVIDUALS OUT OF
THE LOOP.
WHICH I THINK IS TOTALLY
BACKWARDS.
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN WORK ON
THAT HOPEFULLY GOING FORWARD --
AND WANT TO KNOW WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT --
I ACTUALLY AGREE THAT THERE IS A
PURPOSE IN A PLACE.
BUT ALL OF THE DRIVING THAT I'VE
DONE.
S. WAS IS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
EVERY HOV LANE IS COMPLETELY
IMPACTED AND ADDING MORE AND
AGAIN -- I
CAN'T SAY THAT YOU'RE WRONG
LYRIC I GOTTA SAY THAT OUR
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW THOSE
COMPLETELY DEGRADED.
AND SO WITH ADAM HAVE TO HOLD
OLYMPICS NOT VOTE TODAY BUT
BASICALLY OWN WISH YOU THE BEST
LOCKER.
REVERSING THE PROCESS ON WHO
THINK THE ENTIRE SENATORS --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
WE HAVE A FIRST BY FRIEDMAN
SEGUED BY BERMAN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER NOT VOTING FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THERE'S FIVE VOTES OF ONE WILL
LEAVE THE RULE BEEN THANK YOU
LISTENERS WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP
ONE THOUSAND YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SP ONE THOUSAND IS
ABOUT.
EVEY CHARGING AND NOW REMOVING
BARRIERS --
TO ADOPT THE ADOPTION OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES FOR HEAVY DUTY
FLEETS ONE THE BILL PROMOTES
ACCESS TO SPEED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BY INCLUDING THE
PROXIMITY TO FAST CHARGING.
AS PART OF THE CRITERIA IN OUR
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS SP ONE
THOUSAND ALSO MAKES IT VERY
CLEAR THAT OUR PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS IN THE V.
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE MEANT FOR ALL
TYPES OF E. VIS.
INCLUDING PLUG IN HYBRIDS.
THIRD OF THE PRINTER COMPONENT
OF THE BILL.
AYE IS TO ADDRESS THE BARRIERS
TO HEAVY DUTY FLEETS BY
DIRECTING THE CPUC TO CONSIDER A
RATE STRUCTURE SPECIFIC TO THOSE
VEHICLES ELECTRIC TRUCK
TECHNOLOGY LAGS BEHIND.
OUR LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES PRICING
SIGNALS ARE CRITICAL TO THE
STRATEGY OF CHARGING AND SB ONE
THOUSAND PROMOTES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE SIGNAL
STILL RATE STRUCTURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
SPEECH IN NEW REPRESENT PLEASE
COULD ALWAYS SING WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS AND WE SUPPORT SB
ONE THOUSAND WE THINK IS A HI
[inaudible]
STE STRAIGHTFORWARD WAY TO A
HELP REDUCE SOME OF THE BARRIERS
TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT THE
STATE HAS HAS LAID OUT FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES VERY QUICKLY
THAT.
THE GOVERNOR HAS LAID OUT
NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE AT
LEAST FIVE MILLION VEHICLES BY --
TWENTY THIRTY IN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE GOALS OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WHICH WE HAVE A SPOT
THREE MILLION ONE POINT THREE
MILLION --
THEY NEED 992-003-3000 CHARGERS
WE CURRENTLY HAVE. SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CHARGE ON WHAT WE HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO IN SIX AND A
HALF YEARS.
AND WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
HELP US --
CLEAR THAT WAY TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THE STATE'S GOALS
WOULD BE UP MORE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD IS PEOPLE
WILL.
NOT BUY THESE DEALS THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY CAN --
REFUELED AND CHARGE THEM THANK
YOU.
MAKE SPEAKERS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND HE REPRESENT PLEASE. TO
LIKE CATHARINE GARCIA ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HE REMEMBERS THE PUBLIC WITH
QUICK TO US [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
SCORE THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS
REPUBLICAN LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO VOICE HER OPINION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
CENTER REJECT CLOSE THANK YOU
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE ONE MAKE SURE WE ARE
INCLUDE A FAST CHARGES FOR EVERY
IN EVERY COMMUNITY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT NOBODY GETS LEFT
BEHIND --
AND CREATE THE RIGHT MARKET
STRUCTURE TO ALLOW FOR FREE TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE BETTER PRICES
WHEN IT COMES TO MOVIES.
ITEM AND MAKE SURE THAT
DIRECTION INCENTIVIZED TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND SWITCH OUT OF
THESE NEWER TECHNOLOGIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR A BRING
THIS FOR TODAY AND I AGREE WITH
YOU 1100% THAT --
AND HAS.
YOU WITNESSES STATED A WE ARE
VERY FAR BEHIND IN WHAT WE NEED
TO BE AT WE NEED TO BE PUTTING
MORE CHARGING STATIONS OUT.
AND AND AND NOW.
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
MOVING FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY.
OF THE AGENCIES THAT ARE
INVOLVED WILL UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS AN URGENCY AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO KEEP PASSING BILLS TO
INCENTIVIZE AND DO THIS.
I'VE THE FIRST --
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
SECOND BY SO WE WERE BERMAN
BERMAN AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN
AYE CHU.
CHU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS MEDINA
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT IS A SOUND LOOK AT THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSOLUTE THANK YOUS
DRUMMERS THINK SENATOR.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO CENTER
SKINNER --
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AS BEING
[inaudible] TEN FOURTEEN YOU
SEE WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE.
THANK SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
S. B. TEN FOURTEEN RECOGNIZES
THAT ARE VERY CONVENIENT TO RIDE
HAILING SERVICE'S OR
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES
AS THEY'RE CALLED.
ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO HELP
US MEET.
OUR AIR QUALITY IN OUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE GOALS AND AS
YOU'VE JUST BEEN DISCUSSING
ABOUT.
THE GOVERNOR'S TARGET FOR THE
FIVE MILLION E. VIS OR ZAPS ON
THE ROAD BY CERTAIN YEAR AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO BOTH WITH
CHARGING ANOTHER TO GET UP TO
THAT -- THIS
BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO SO. TO
ASSIST NOT ONLY BY ANY MEANS BUT
ONE I AM PLEASED TO INFORM YOU
IS THAT.
WITH THE WORK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS RECOMMENDED AND
OTHER DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS --
THE TNC COMPANIES LIKE UBER AND
LEFT AND TECH NET AND OTHERS
HAVE NOW REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL --
AND I WANTED TO JUST.
BRIEFLY STATE WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE THAT WILL BE
TAKING AND THAT --
IN THE COMMITTEE.
THEY ARE WE ARE TYING THE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION AND ZERO
EMISSION GOALS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER WE ARE DETAILING
WHAT DATA.
THE AMENDMENT WILL DETAIL WHAT
DATA WILL BE REQUIRED FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES.
AND WHATEVER GOALS ARE SET
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THE BILL
THE STANDARDS IN THE BILL WOULD
BE IF AND MET FAIRLY ACROSS ALL
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES.
AND WE WOULD REQUIRE EXISTING
STATE PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT SAID
SO FOR EXAMPLE ARE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM AND OTHER
PROGRAMS ARE CHARGING
INVESTMENTS IN CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WOULD TAKE.
WHATEVER GOALS THAT ARE SET BY A
ARE BEING PCS RESULT OF THIS
BILL.
THEY WOULD TAKE THEM INTO
CONSIDERATION.
ON AND WITH THAT --
CENTER DREDGES OR IS MAYES
STATEMENT SO YOU'VE AGREED TO
TAKE ALL THE LIMON YEAH ELVES --
LET ME LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS.
WE GET MY STUFF UP TO MAKE SURE
[inaudible]
YES YES.
YES RECUSE WONDERFULLY
[inaudible]
GO.
YOU HAVE WITNESSES QUIRK YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
PER SQUARE BALL SOME BEHALF
VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW WE ARE A
NON PROSTATE THAT ADMINISTERS
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM.
I IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
NOW BY OFFERING UP TO NINETY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN STATE
INCENTIVES WE'VE HELPED LOW
INCOME --
FOLKS LIVING AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES REPLACE OVER A
THOUSAND OLDER HIGH POLLUTING
VEHICLES --
WITH MORE EFFICIENT OR ZERO
EMISSION ONCE --
THIS INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BEEN
VERY EFFECTIVE AT ATTRACTING LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS --
TO A PLUG IN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
WHO WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE NOT
CONSIDERED IT --
AND THEREFORE WE THINK THIS IS A
VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL THAT CAN
HELP IMPLEMENT THE GOALS OF S.
B. TEN FOURTEEN AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GONNA BE HALF
THE CAL EXCUSE ME THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION --
ANTI SEIZE A BAY AREA TWENTY
FORTY PLANNING KNOWLEDGES THAT.
CLEAN VEHICLES ARE GOING BE THE
KEY TO REDUCING THE REGION'S. TO
TCI THE REGION'S CLIMATE GOALS.
HALF OF THE BAY AREA'S READ READ.
COMMISSION REDUCTIONS ARE GOING
TO COME FROM ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
AS TNC TRIPS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE A GREENER TNC FLEET
WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT.
GROWTH IN RIDE HAILING CAN
SUPPORT THE BAY AREA'S EFFORTS
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS WASTAGE
NAMED YOU.
REPRESENT PLEASE.
MR JR MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF CAL START IN AFRICA THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILL PARENT WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO EXPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROCKY RUSSIAN
WITH COLLEGE FOR CLEAN AIR ON WE
HAVE CCA AND THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B..
TEN FORTY BUT JULIE ON ASK ABOUT
HALF THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION WE HAVE
A SUPPORT POSITION WHILE WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
IN PARTICULAR THE THE LANGUAGE
AROUND THE UTILITY THE PILOT
PROGRAMS --
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US ON
THIS THINKING.
CATHERINE GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE
BRANDENBURG ON BEHALF OF CINEMA
CLEAN POWER HOPE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT WE WILL REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE OR STANCE
POINT THINKING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN
QUITE QUICKLY PARK CAMPAIGN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SIR CHEN ARABS WILL BE
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUB FIGHT TO TEST WINDS OR THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS
BUILDER VOICE OUR OPINION PLEASE
COME UP TO THE PEOPLE.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND HE
REPRESENTING PLEASE.
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER ALSO NAY WORTH
WITH UBER --
AS THE AUTHOR POINTED OUT WERE
HAPPY TO MOVE TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION WITH THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN FULL AND THE COMMITTEES
AND ALSO SOMETHING FOR THE GOOD
WORK -- JUST
IT BRIEFLY PROVIDE SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE ISSUE --
WE BELIEVE THE RIGHT TRYING
ABSOLUTE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN A
TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON
ECONOMY.
SIMPLY GETTING MORE IF HE'S ON
THE RIGHT TRAIN PLATFORM NOT
JUST GETS.
EVEN IS THAT OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
LIMITED ASSET ON THE ROADS TODAY
BE USED AT A HIGHER FREQUENCY
BUT SHARE WITH MORE FOLKS AND
GIVEN THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS OF
GETTING THE FIVE MILLIONS AS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND THE RAMP UP
TOWARDS THAT IS I IS GOING HAVE
MORE IMPACT INVOLVED MORE PEOPLE
AUTHOR USE IN THE SHIRT CASSIDY --
THE BILL NOW HAS A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT BETTER CAPTURES
TEENS HE'S CLIMATE IMPACT.
THROUGH WHICH TRANSITION IS OUR
MISSION IN VEHICLES JUST ONE
COMPONENT OF MANY THINGS WE CAN
DO TAX REDUCE OUR CLIMATE
IMPACTS --
BUT THE BILL DOES NOT CONSIDER
IT WOULD ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER GOING FORWARD.
IS INCENTIVIZING CLEARING THE
OBSTACLES FOR THE DESIRED
OUTCOME IN THE BILL WHICH IS
MORE MORE CLEAN ELECTRIC MILES
AND AND REDUCTION IN EMISSIONS
IN THE RIGHT TRYING SECTOR.
THESE ALL THESE ARTICLES INCLUDE
THE FACT THAT YOU THE TNC JOBS
TODAY ARE OFTEN WERE OFF DUE TO
RANGE LIMITATIONS DOWNTIME
CHARGING THEIR VEHICLES AND JUST
GENERAL LACK OF PUBLIC AVAILABLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AMONG OTHER ISSUES --
WITHOUT THE SIGNIFICANT MARKET
INFECTIOUS CHANGES WHICH SOME
BILLSYOU ARE TO CONSIDER TODAY
ADDRESS --
THE MAKING THESE MORE
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE DRIVERS OF
POTENTIALLY EARN LESS AND EVEY
DRIVING FOR UBER AND LEFT.
SO COLLECTIVELY ADDRESSING THE
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS IS
CHOOSING TO BUY ANY V. --
FOR RIGHT TRAIN PURPOSE WHEN
THEY'RE IN THE MARKET TO BUY --
BUT THIS BILL TARGETS ONLY
EIGHTEEN SEASON WHILE FAILING TO
LEVERAGE ANY POLICIES THAT WOULD
CAPITALIZE ON THE ON THE
POTENTIAL RIDE SHARING OFFERS.
WHO ENCOURAGED THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER THAT THOSE THINGS GOING
FOR BUT WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORK ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU SWEETEST PLEASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOCUMENT
FACTORED REPRESENTING LEFT ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR FOR FOR DILIGENCE IN WORKING
WITH US.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS --
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS --
LIVE TO HAS REMOVED ITS
OPPOSITION AND WILL GO TO
NEUTRAL NOW.
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR TO THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL NAMELY THE ISSUE OF
WORKING WITH THE THAT THE I USE
AND OTHERS TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A FRAMEWORK.
CONTINUE FRAMEWORK FOR MOVING
FORWARD ON FAST CHARGING
STATIONS.
THANK YOU WITH WITH THIS ONE
LIKE MORE ABOUT IT WITH TECH
GNATS I I LIKE THAT PIECE
SPEAKERS WITH THE AUTHOR'S WORK
IN THE STOCKS WORK ON THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS BEING
ACCEPTED WE REMOVE OPPOSITION
AGO MITCHELL ON THE BILL.
ANY OTHER.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO LIKE
TO SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF WE
SERPENT.
SING ON ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE A QUESTION MISTER FUNG.
I JUST THAT IF YOU CAN PROVIDE
ME SOME SOME --
BACKGROUND OUR OUR DATA I KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE SOME FOLKS THERE
FROM OVER THE CENTER VALLEY
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN THE CENTER
VALLEY.
ALLOW FOLKS THAT DRIVE --
FOR UBER AND LIFT AND IT'S IT
SAYS THERE THEY COME FROM ALL OF
US SPECTRUMS OF THE IF INCOME
LEVEL BUT OF COURSE THOSE WHO
ARE.
STRUGGLING A DR UBER AND LEFT TO
TO TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND SO --
THE TNC IS ON THE COMPANIES THEY
DON'T ON THE VEHICLES.
THE PERSONAL DRIVER THAT'S A
PROVIDING SERVICE WITH THEIR OWN
VEHICLES SO IF THEY CAN'T AFFORD.
TO TO PURCHASE --
A AS EVER BUT THE MOMENT HOW
DOES THIS IMPACT THEIR ABILITY
TO MAKE AN INCOME.
SO THE WAY THE BILL IS
STRUCTURED BOTH IN BOTH WHEN IT
WAS FIRST INTRODUCED AND EVEN AS
AMENDED.
THE BILL WOULD NOT AFFECT ALL
[inaudible]
TNC DRIVERS.
AND IT IS.
DESIGNED TO AFFECT MILES.
ON THAT OR AS DEPLOYED ON THE
TNC PLATFORM SO HYPOTHETICALLY
THAT COULD MEAN THAT ONLY THOSE
HIGH HIGH VOLUME DRIVERS.
NOW CONCEIVABLY A HIGH VOLUME
DRIVER CAN BE LOW INCOME BUT ARE
AND CLEAN OUR CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE.
PROGRAM HAS 25% OF IT DEDICATED
TO LOW INCOME DRIVERS --
A. B. D. GOALS ARE ALSO THERE'S
NO 100% GOAL IN THE BILL AND THE
HARD TARGETS ARE REMOVED SO THIS
ALLOWS FOR THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES TO FACTOR THINGS LIKE.
THE AVAILABILITY OF VEHICLES
THEIR RANGE THEIR COSTS IN THOSE
THINGS IN SETTING THE GOALS THAT
THEY ADOPT FOR IT SO IT'S
DESIGNED TO BE VERY FLEXIBLE. TO
FACTOR --
THOSE THINGS AROUND RANGING
AROUND INCOME OF DRIVERS AND ALL
OF THAT.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY SO SO THE
MANDATE.
THE MANDATE TO TWO AM A THE
FLEET MANDATE THAT THERE'S
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT.
THERE IT'S WRITTEN NOW WHERE ON
A ARE BE WOULD INITIALLY.
BASED ON EMISSIONS FOR DOING A
BASELINE EMISSIONS PROFILE OF
THE TNC COMPANIES WOULD SET THE
GOALS AND THEN P. YOU SEE WOULD
ADMINISTER.
THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK AS THEY
DO NOW THEY ARE THERE REGULATORY
ENTITY FOR PNC'S.
AND AND WHAT ARE THE GLOBAL DID
DID OTHER GOALS FLETCHER HARM
THEIR HEART GOALS ARE OUT OF THE
BILL.
ANY OTHER USE THROUGH GOOGLE.
AYE YES I OF THE FIRST SO I WANT
TO THANK THE OFFER THE AUTHOR OF
HER -- FOR
FOR HER OR LONG STANDING
SUPPORTER CLEANER AND THAT'S I
THINK WITH THE GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS -- BUT I
HAVE SOME CHALLENGES WITH THIS
BILL AND I THINK YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD THEM.
IN MY MY CONCERN IS THAT IT
FURTHER EMPOWERS CARP --
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I SEE FROM
THE IS THE FROM IT WILL THE
STATE LEGISLATORS I I FEEL LIKE.
I I'M ACCOUNTABLE CARB CARDS ON
ACCOUNTABLE TO ME.
AS A STATE LEGISLATOR OR EVEN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND MY WORRY IS THAT THIS
FURTHERS THAT DYNAMIC --
OF A LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY IN
WHERE WE WERE HEADING OVER.
SOME SIGNIFICANT AUTHORITY AND I
JUST DON'T KNOW THERE'S MANY
BARRIERS ON AND I DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO GO.
I MEAN YOU COULD SAY THAT ABOUT
ANY BILL BUT I THINK IN THIS
CASE IT'S PRETTY EXPLICIT
THEY'RE HANDING THEM A A MISSION.
AND AND AND AND AGAIN MY CONCERN
IS IS WHERE DOES THIS GO.
TO YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT
AND DO CARE TO WORLD SO THE THE
BILL DOES NOT --
AUTHORITY SO IN OTHER WORDS A
ARE BE.
THE REGULATORY ENTITY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR REGULATING TMZ'S
REMAINS THE P. UC SO ANY.
ANY --
ADMINISTRATION ANY ADOPTION OF
REGULATIONS OR ADMINISTRATION OF
REGULATIONS WOULD STILL SQUARE
STAY SQUARELY WITH THE PC.
WHAT CARBS RULE WOULD BE IN THIS
IS UPON THE RECOMMENDATION IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH OUR TNC
COMPANIES?
BECAUSE THE OBJECTIVE YES IT IS
I'VE CHARACTERIZED IT AS ZEV PSE
AND CLEAN MILES IT REALLY IS
THAT YOUR QUALITY ISSUE.
SO BECAUSE TAILPIPE EMISSIONS
STILL ARE THE NUMBER ONE SOURCE
OF AIR POLLUTING EMISSIONS.
AND CALIFORNIA'S STILL HAS A
LARGE MAJORITY OF ITS --
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS IN NON
ATTAINMENT DISTRICTS SO WHAT.
A ARBY'S ROLE WOULD BE IS TO
WORK WITH THE TNC EAST TO SET A
BASELINE OF THEIR EMISSIONS
PROFILE AT PRESENT.
AND THEN TO WORK OUT AS
RECOMMENDED SET OF GOALS FOR HOW
DO TO IN EFFECT CLEAN THOSE
SMILES BRING DOWN THE EMISSIONS
OF THOSE MILES.
WHICH THEN THE P. YOU SEE WOULD --
BASICALLY --
ADMINISTER THOUGH THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN THEY DON'T HAVE.
TO JUST GUT THERE'S FLEXIBILITY
IN TERMS OF THE TIMING AND IN
TERMS OF HOW IT'S DONE BASED ON
ALL THESE FACTORS LIKE
AVAILABILITY OF VEHICLES.
COST VEHICLES RANGE AND THAT
SORT OF THING.
OKAY THANK YOUNG GUY --
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE BUT I
THINK MY CONCERNS REMAIN THIS
BUT I DO YOU FOR YEARS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF CATHOLIC
CHURCH SECULAR MUCH CHILD SOLIS
WHO THANKED AUTHOR.
FULL FOR THIS BILL ON DEUCE IS
REALLY NOT NEW --
MOST SOLVE TO TAXI COMPANIES
DON'T DO CITIES WERE VERY
CHERISHED THE LOCAL AGENCIES
TELL US HOW THE REQUIREMENT.
OF THEIR FLEET HOW HOW ME CARD
HOUSE COULD BE A ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES SO --
I I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TAXI
COMPANIES ARE LEFT IN THE
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THIS IS TO A WAY TO REALLY --
OF PROMOTE A MORE TING WEARS HER
AND TO TO DO THE TNC SONG BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE CENTER WAS LIKE
CLOTHES.
THANKS SO MUCH SO IN --
BECAUSE I CARRIED A BILL LAST
YEAR WHICH COMMITTEE SUPPORTED
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW
THAT GOT AFTER THAT LOOKED AT
OUR FLEETS SO BOTH CODIFIED DEBT
STATE OWNED FLEETS WOULD HAVE TO
BECOME A CERTAIN PERCENT. ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES OVER CERTAIN
NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND WE WOULD ALSO MOVE TOWARDS
INCENTIVIZING PRIVATE SECTOR
FLEETS --
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY.
YOU KNOW MOST OF US IF WE LEAVE
JUST YOU AND I THE REGULAR
DRIVER -- TO
TO HELP CALIFORNIA MEET OUR ZERO
MISSION GOALS WE DON'T.
CHANGE OUR OWNERSHIP OF VEHICLES
FAST ENOUGH WE WE HOLD ON TOWARD
VEHICLES WHICH IS A CAN BE A
GOOD THING.
AND YET IT IS FLEET OWNERS AND
HIGH VM TIER HIGH VOLUME DRIVERS
THAT CHANGE THEIR VEHICLES MORE
FREQUENTLY IN OTHER WORDS
PURCHASE NEW ONES [inaudible]
AND SO WHAT --
WHAT MY DIFFERENT PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ARE TRYING TO DO IS
GET AT TRYING TO CREATE THAT
KIND OF MARKET SIGNAL SO THAT
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE MORE?
OFTEN GONNA CHANGE VEHICLE MOVE
INTO OUR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
[inaudible]
AND IN MY OPENING I REFERENCED
AND THANK YOU --
CHAIR FOR CLARIFYING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS I'VE TAKEN WHICH ARE
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS HAVE
REMOVED THE OPPOSITION SO
TECHNET UBER LIFTER NO LONGER
OPPOSED.
AND I THINK THIS --
MEETS THAT KIND OF BALANCE OF
CREATING ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY AND
YET ALLOWS OTHER ENTITIES TO BE
PARTNERS WITH THE STATE IN
MEETING OUR CLEAN AIR AND OUR
CLIMATE PROTECTION CALLS WITHOUT
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR --
FROM THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
MY COMMITTEE IN AND WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON ON THIS BILL
[inaudible]
OF IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING AND
THEY THEY'VE.
VOIGTS SAID TODAY THAT THEY'VE
TAKEN EITHER INTO A NEUTRAL.
OF NOT OPPOSING THE THE BILL.
I THINK WHAT WERE.
HEARING THOUGH HIS.
FROM MEMBERS OFTEN ON THE
GENERAL --
APPREHENSION [inaudible]
ABOUT -- THE
THE AIRPORT HAVING ANY KIND OF
REGULATORY.
AUTHORITY OVER ANY ENTITY.
OF BEING ABLE TO DO THIS AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL IT HAD
POINTED OUT OF WE WANT THEM TO
BECOME A PARTNER.
AND AND WORK WITH US THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO SOME OF THE
LOW HANGING FRUIT AN ADMIRABLE
GOALS WITHOUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WOULD MAYBE LIKE REDUCING
CONGESTION.
OF THE PORTS.
MY BEYOND THE LOW HANGING FRUIT
THAT WE CAN ALL.
GET BEHIND TOGETHER YOU KNOW AND
ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
ACCOMPLISHMENTS --
YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
GET FIVE MILLION ZONES OUT --
WHICH WITHOUT GIVE STRUCTURES
WILL BE ALMOST ON ON ON
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO.
SO YOU KNOW WE NEED TO BECOME A
PARTNER OF WITH THESE AGENCIES
TO TO ACCOMPLISH THIS.
LAUDABLE GOALS BUT AGAIN --
I APPRECIATE THE ABILITY FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY.
AND AND THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
LOW INCOME.
DRIVERS --
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY UTILIZES AS A
SOURCE OF INCOME AS A SAFETY NET
FOR THEMSELVES.
SO WITH THAT IN IN YOUR GOOD
WORK COMING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY SO.
HOW WE HAVE A FIRST BIKE MISTER
KANSEN CHU AND SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN?
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG NO
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN I HATE
YOU.
CHIU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON ON GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL NO.
IT HAS SEVEN IS ONE MORE LIKELY
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINKING
[inaudible]
SIR MCGUIRE.
THE FILE ITEM.
NINE S. B..
TEN TWENTY NINE RECEIVED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
I ALSO WANT TO STATE THAT --
I WANT TO THANK --
SENATOR BATES FOR HER PATIENTS
HER THINK SHE'S BEEN VERY
PATIENT.
PRESUMING YOU READY.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
UP FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND KNOWS
BEEN --
CRAZY DAVE THANK YOU MEMBERS AS
WELL FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
GRATEFUL TO BE A PRESENT SENATE
BILL [inaudible]
TEN TWENTY NINE AND IT'S ALL
ABOUT THE GREAT RIVER TRAIL ACT
I JUST OR EVEN A QUICKLY AT THIS
IS A DISTRICT BILL WHERE THE
CURRENT RAILROAD THAT HAD.
NOT BEEN OPERATING MANY DECADES
AGO THROUGH FIVE OF THE SEVEN
COUNTIES ARE NORTH COAST
DISTRICT HUMBOLDT TRINITY
MENDOCINO CINEMA AND MARINE.
THE LINE IS CURRENTLY OWNED BY
THE NORTH COAST RAILROAD
AUTHORITY WHICH WAS CREATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IT JUST
ORIENT YOU A THROUGH THE CHAIR.
SINCE THE RUNS FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY --
WELL OVER THREE HUNDRED MILES
ALL THE WAY UP TO THE HUMBOLDT
BAY TO SOME OF THE MOST
PICTURESQUE.
A POSTCARD LANDSCAPES ON THE
PLANET NOW AFTER MONTHS OF
RESEARCH AND DISCUSION LAST
YEAR I WE WERE SADDENED TO BE A
TO CONCLUDE THAT REBUILDING MUCH
OF THIS.
RAIL WAS SIMPLY NOT FEASIBLE.
AB BOTH FINANCIALLY OR
PHYSICALLY THE REMOTENESS OF THE
LINE THE LACK OF SHIPPERS IN THE
EXTREME GEOTECHNICAL CHALLENGES
ALL COMBINE TO MAKE THIS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE PROJECT.
AT THIS POINT IN CRA ALSO HAS NO
ABILITY TO BE A DEAL WITH THE
PROBLEMS THAT THEY FACE.
THEY HAVE RACKED UP OVER NINE
MILLION IN DEBT OVER THE YEARS
AND ARE LISTED BY THE STATE AS
BEING A HIGH RISK AGENCY.
THEY HAVE NO MORE SAVINGS IN ARE
LEGALLY WITHIN A COUPLE OF
MONTHS OF NOT BEING ABLE TO PAY
THEIR EMPLOYEES.
THEIR RENT OR THEIR BASIC BILLS
BUT THAT ISN'T THE END OF WE NOW
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REMAKE
THIS RIGHT AWAY INTO SOMETHING
SPECTACULAR FOR THE NORTH COAST
IN THE ENTIRE GOLDEN STATE.
WE'RE PROPOSING TO BUILD TO
BUILD A WORLD CLASS TRAIL FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY. TO THE
INCREDIBLY BEAUTY IS THE
INCREDIBLE BEAUTY WINE COUNTRY
INTO THE STUNNING OLD GROWTH
REDWOOD FORCE ALONGSIDE THE
RUSSIAN INYO RIVERS AND UP TO
THE PANORAMIC HUMBOLDT BAY.
AND THAT IS WHAT IS BEFORE YOU
TODAY THE NCR A WILL BE
DISSOLVED THROUGH SENATE BILL
TEN TWENTY NINE IN A THREE
HUNDRED MILE LONG RIGHT AWAY
WILL BE DIVIDED ROUGHLY AT THE
HALFWAY POINT.
WITH THE EXISTING SINAMA MARINE
AREA RAIL TRANSIT AGENCY RUNNING
OPERATIONS IN THE SOUTH IN THE
NEWLY ESTABLISHED GREAT RABBIT
TRAIL AGENCY WOULD MANAGE
OPERATIONS IN THE NORTH.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD ON THIS
PROJECT OVER THE LAST A YEAR IN
THERE HAD BEEN SOME FINANCIAL
DETAILS THAT NEED TO BE WORKED
OUT AMONGST THE PARTIES WHICH
WERE CURRENTLY I DOING RIGHT NOW.
BUT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
DECADES MISTER CHAIR EVERYONE IS
IT TO THE TABLE TO HELP CREATE A
BETTER FUTURE FOR THIS AMAZING
RIGHT AWAY.
AND WOULD APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WILLINGNESS BETTER
LET US PROCEED NINETY ONE AS A
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR ALL
THIS WORK ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THIS THAT
WRAPPED UP I'D TO THINK YOU SO
MUCH TO ADD SOME NUMBER GIPSON
AYE IN CLOSING I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO NO VOTES THUS
FAR EVER AGREED THE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT A TWO DAY WE'VE JOE
FILM --
BOARD HA HERE TODAY.
AS WELL AS SYMBOLIC REPRESENTING
THE SIMMERING AREA HOW TRANSIT
AUTHORITY.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE WITNESSES
SPORTS SENATOR YES PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU REPRESENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE EMINEM'S JOYFUL
BORA AND I'M GONNA CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY NINE BECAUSE THIS BILL
PROVIDES A VEHICLE TO ADDRESS
ONGOING CONCERNS REGARDING THE
FUTURE AND VIABILITY OF THE
NORTH COAST RAILROAD AUTHORITY.
AS MUCH OF MY SENATOR MCGUIRE.
IF YOU TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND FURY
STATED IN A PRESENTATIONS ARE
COMMISSION THAT IT WAS HAVING
DIFFICULTY MAINTAINING AN
EXPANDING RAIL SERVICE HAS NEVER
BEEN SELF SUFFICIENT.
AND WAS ROUTINELY UNABLE TO PAY
ITS OBLIGATIONS AND RESPONSE
MISINFORMATION THE COMMISSION
INCLUDED A RECOMMENDATION IN ITS
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO FORM A COMMITTEE OF
STAKEHOLDERS. TO OVERSEE A
DEVELOPMENT OF A PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE STATUTORY CREATED
ENTERPRISE.
FAST FORWARD ENGINEER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND SCARY PRESENTED
THEIR STRATEGIC PLAN TO THE
COMMISSION AND UNFORTUNATELY.
S. PLAN FAILED TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
AUTHORITIES FINANCIAL VIABILITY
TO ALLAY CONCERNS.
THE COMMISSION BELIEVES THAT THE
OBLIGATIONS AND ASSETS AND FURY
NEED TO BE TRANSITIONED INTO NEW
MANAGEMENT AND WE COMMEND CENTER
REQUIRES LEADERSHIP AND
PROPOSING SOLUTIONS. TO PROTECT
THE STATE THE STATE'S RIGHT OF
WAY AND PROVIDE CONTINUING
BENEFITS A PUBLIC.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY NINE AM ALSO HAPPY
ANSWERING.
THINK IT'S WITH THE SPECIFIC
ADOPTING STEVE ALL COMING UP THE
SNOW MARIN AERIAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT ROLL SINGERS FOR THE
BILL.
ABSENT THAT SMART IS UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO ACCEPTED THE ASSETS
IN HERE EITHER CURRENTLY
OPERATING RAIL SERVICE FROM US
IN AMERICA FOR DOWN --
TO CENTER FELL IN CONSTRUCTION
WAIT LARKSPUR AS WELL AS
PLANNING GOING UP FOR WINDSOR
ALITA --
HEALDSBURG AND CLOVERDALE --
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL WE THINK THE SET PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR A FUTURE --
OF THAT WOULD PROVIDE BOTH
REALTORS THE TRAIL GOING ALL THE
WAY ALONG.
THANK YOU EX WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE AND
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBERTS IT WAS SHOT HERE IT'S WE
ON BEHALF OF CINEMA COUNTY --
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL'S GOING TO
HAVES SOME VERY REAL BENEFITS ON
TRANSPORTATION THE COUNTY AS
WELL AS PROVIDING SOME
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR RESIDENTS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TALK
HOUSTON REPRESENTED THE
CALIFORNIA PARK RECREATION
SOCIETY WE TOO ARE IN SUPPORT.
ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE AND THE
WEAPONS CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH
PTEROCLIFORMESFAMILY.
Q. ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEN NINE I MEAN THERE WAS THE
PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
WE CITRONELLA PRESENTING PLEASE.
THINK YOU TAILOR RUSHED WOOD
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE DO YOU
HAVE AN OPPOSED LESS AMENDED
POSITION REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS --
WITH THE LAST FEW WEEKS IRONING
OUT AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE SENATORS WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US.
AND WE'D BE GLADLY REMOVE OUR
POSITION FUTURE [inaudible]
THANKS FAQ.
IT OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THAT
I DESPITE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
NONE.
CENTERS LIKE CLOTHES WOULD
RESPECT FAST AND I DON'T THINK
MISTER CHAIR.
KIM THIS EMOTION [inaudible]
IF MOST.
WE NEED A SECOND.
SEX FROM PURSUED BY.
GIPSON SEGMENT FRIEDMAN.
SIR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
STICKING IN THE AIR ON THIS
ARDUOUS TASK.
I DEFINITELY AGREE THAT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE WITH
A AND SEE OUR A AND YOU HAVE A
LOT OF ISSUES TO WORK AND ROUTE
RESOLVE.
A WITH THIS BILL BEFORE AUGUST
THE GOVERNOR.
HAM AND NOT A LOT OF TIME LEFT.
AND SO ISSUE THE BETTER VERY
BEST OF LUCK BECAUSE IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO GET DONE.
AND WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR IT IS A BIG HOT MESS SO
I AM VERY GRATEFUL UP FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK ATTY ALL YOUR TIME ON
THIS THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS AS WELL.
WITH THAT MID SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER FRAZIER IPHONE.
FONG NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING MATHIS
[inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I'VE.
THAT IS A WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
OPENED FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU CENTER.
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU BEING
SOLD.
LESLIE NIELSEN OKAY CENTER BASE
LOOK LIKE IT'S YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING PATIENT.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN S. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY ONE CHRIS PLEASE I
THINK THAT'S A FINDING GO
QUICKIE GUY SO I WILL.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU KNOW YOU'VE
READ URINALYSIS S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY ONE SEEKS TO EXPAND THE
USE OF NEIGHBORHOOD ELECTRIC BE
VEHICLES SAN DIEGO COUNTY --
THEY ARE CLEAN INNOVATIVE FORMER
TRANSPORTATION THAT CAN REACH
SPEEDS OF TWENTY FIVE MILES PER
HOUR.
NOW THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN ANY CITY IN
THIS BOUNDARY TO ESTABLISH
TRANSPORTATION.
PLANS WITH HER ON ANY OF THESE
EXISTING ALREADY PERMIT SON
NEVER TRANSPORTATION PLANS. FOR
MANY OUR LOCATIONS INCLUDING THE
CITIES OF FRESNO JACKSON LINCOLN
ROCKLIN INSIDER CREEK AS WELL AS
THE COUNTIES OF ON THE DOOR AND
RIVERSIDE.
SO WE'RE JUST HOPING TO BRING
THE SNAPS TO SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WITHOUT ALASKA ROBIN WAGNER WELL
THERE WHO IS WITH SAN DIEGO IS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
ANSWER.
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU ALL
MIGHT HELP PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN SIR VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
RAVENLOFT NOW WITH THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS ARE
SAND THAT THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCY.
CHRIS AND EAGLE COUNTY SENATOR
B. THIRTY COVERED ALL THE MAIN
POINTS OF THE BILL I JUST
REITERATE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR EACH OF OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE
TO USE.
ON TO SAY HOW AND WHERE NEXT
FROM SAN THAT'S PERSPECTIVE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
INVASION THE EXPANDED USE OF
PUBLICLY SHARED MASS AS A WAY TO
HELP ME ARE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY CALLS.
ON IT'S ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO IMPLEMENT THEIR LOCAL CLIMATE
ACTION PLANNING GOALS AS WELL AS
A REGIONAL SUSTAINABILITY AND
TRANSPORTATION GOALS.
SO WITH THAT SANTA GETS PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL WE THINK
SENATOR BEATS YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS AND WE REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MIX WITH THE SWITCH.
KURT BLACKBURN AVAILS AND WILSON
ADVOCACY ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
SAN DIEGO --
HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE CITY
VINSON IS ONE OF THE CITY'S
WITHIN SAN DIEGO COUNTY HERE IN
SUPPORT TAKE YOU NEXT WITNESS
WITH MIKE.
GOOD EVENING CARE ALSO HAVE TO
CITY OF SAN MARCOS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
AT JULIE NON ASK BOBBY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
ANDREA ENTRY WHICH EARLIER AND
WE ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY WE SUPPORT.
MAC LEGACY IN BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY IN
SPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA WAS SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IN THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE.
TO TEST FINE OPPOSITION OF WAS
HER OPINION ON THE AUTHORS BILL.
SINGLE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR WOODS LIKE CLOTHES JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR BATES I BELIEVE IF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REALLY WANT TO
ESTABLISH THESE TYPES OF PLANS
DID THEY GET THE APPROPRIATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
SO IT FITS WHERE THEY WORK WHERE
FITS --
THEREFORE UNWILLING SPREE BILL
TODAY AND SEPARATE PLEASE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN
AYE CHU.
CHU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON [inaudible]
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
ODOM [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT IS NOT IN ITS
OWN WILL WE'VE RULED CONTRACTS
MEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU
.
SO SERGEANTS ARE LOOKING.
TO FIND SCOTT MORE AUTHORS AND
SO IF YOU MISS DALY SHOW.
LET'S GO INTO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
A WE DO SOME.
NOW IT'S ON THE MEASURE OF
CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE IS HERE.
TO TWO ZERO ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO ACR.
TWO FIFTY FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
S. B. NINE OH SEVEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SP.
TWO NINE EIGHTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
TEN SP.
TEN EIGHTY FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN S. B..
ELEVEN TWELVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO S. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE S. YOUR
NINETY TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR S. YOUR ONE ZERO
FIVE FILE ITEM.
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE S. YOU ARE
ONE TWELFTH.
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX
AT ZERO ONE TWENTY FOUR I HAVE A
FIRST BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PHONE SEX MY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ORDER ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE
FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON [inaudible]
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA IDEAS ARYAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I IT'S A KILLER IS TEN
ZERO LEAVE THE ROLE CONFIRMED
ABSENT MEMBERS WILL DO A LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING RIGHT NOW --
MEASURES OFF FILE.
A FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB.
SEVEN SIXTY SOME IN ORG CENTER
WON'T WINNER HAS BEEN PULLED.
AND FILE ITEM. EIGHTEEN GAINES
SP THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ALSO
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
IT WOULD JUST BE WAITING FOR HIS
MOTHER'S
.
SENATOR HILL WILL START WITH THE
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO SEE WHEN
YOU'RE READY SIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PROMPT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTY TO SIMPLY MAKE
SURE THE PUNISHMENT FITS THE
CRIME IT RESTORES JUDICIAL
COUNCILS DISCRETION IN SETTING
THE FINE FOR FAILING TO COME TO
A COMPLETE STOP.
BEFORE TURNING RIGHT AT A RED
LIGHT THIS MEASURE HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN PRIOR
ITERATIONS AS YOU MAY RECALL
CURRENTLY WHEN A DRIVER DOES NOT
COME TO A COMPLETE STOP AT A RED
LIGHT WHEN MAKING A RIGHT HAND
TURN.
AND DOES WHAT IS COMMONLY CALLED
A CALIFORNIA STOP THAT DRIVER
COULD BE FACING A TICKET OF OVER
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY TWO ALLOWS
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO SET THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PARTICULAR
VIOLATION MOST MINOR TRAFFIC
VIOLATIONS INCLUDING FAILURE TO
YIELD TO PEDESTRIANS.
FAILING TO STOP AT A STOP SIGN
OR MAKING AN UNSAFE TURN HAVE
THIRTY FIVE DOLLAR BASED FINE
TICKET AMOUNTS.
WE DISOBEYED JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WILL SET THIS VIOLATION AT
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS BUT IS LEFT
UP TO THEM.
RIGHT TURN ON RED VIOLATIONS
WILL STILL BE ILLEGAL WILL STILL
AT A POINT TO A DRIVER'S RECORD
IN WILL STILL ALLOW FOR TRAFFIC
SCHOOL S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY TWO
ONLY IMPACTS.
THE BASE FINE AMOUNT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
THERE --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TIM CHIANG WITH THE
AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
I GET WE HAVE SUPPORTED THIS
BILL A A NUMBER OF TIMES AND WE
SUPPORTED NOW --
THE HUNDRED DOLLAR TRAFFIC FINE
WAS REALLY MEANT AND WE'VE
SUBMITTED --
DECLARATION FROM --
ASSEMBLYMAN SHELLEY STAFF PERSON
WHO WORKED ON THAT DATA ITEM
BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
HUNDRED DOLLAR FINE WAS NEVER
MEANT FOR OF THIS RIGHT TO
VIOLATION WE ARCHRIVAL.
THEY FIT ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO LIKE.
TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC FACT LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VOICE
HER OPINION OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEE NINE INNINGS.
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR WAS LIKE CLOSED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM ABOUT
MEMBERS IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL WITH MY COMMITTEE --
THIS BILL RESTORES JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IN SETTING A FINE FOR
A MOVING VIOLATION AND NO WHERE
NEAR.
AS DANGEROUS OR DEADLY IS
RUNNING A RED LIGHT --
WHILE STILL GIVING THAT YOU
JUDICIARY THE DISCRETION TO
INCREASE THE FINE IF THE TERMS
PARTICULARLY RECKLESS SO GIVES A
LOT OF FUN.
DISCRETION WHAT WHAT IS AND WHAT
ISN'T [inaudible]
HARMFUL [inaudible]
SO MASON.
IT'S MORE YOUR BILL TODAY I HAD
A FIRST BY SOME MISTER BERMAN.
A SECOND BY.
WHO'S MY SECOND.
MISTER CHIU WE'VE SECOND THAT --
SO A FIRST OR SECOND BY BERMAN
AND CHU ON MEANT SECTARIAN
PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VETTING GIPSON
[inaudible]
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I GIPSON AYE.
THERE'S A LITTLE LIBERAL ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THINKING
HOW GOOD IT WAS LIKE TO GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY I WOULD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SIX INSURERS CALIFORNIA'S
DISABLED CITIZENS HAVE ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES
SERVICES.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT TECHNICAL
INNOVATION ALMOST ALWAYS
BENEFITS THE DISABLED DISABILITY
COMMUNITY WHICH HAVE BEEN TRUE
OF THE TNC EASE WHICH HAVE MADE
PROGRESS IN PROVIDING ACCESS TO
DEAF AND BLIND PERSONS AS WELL
AS ELDERLY NEEDING.
EXTRA ASSISTANCE THE WHEELCHAIR
USERS ESPECIALLY NON FOLDING
MOTORIZED WHEELCHAIR USERS HAVE
NOTED THE CLEAR LACK OF ACCESS
TO THE SERVICES TNC IS PROVIDE.
MANY LOCALITIES LIKE SEATTLE AND
CHICAGO HAVE ADDRESS THIS
DISPARITY BY ASSISTING A
SURCHARGE ON TNC USED TO HELP
PAY FOR ACCESSIBLE TRANSIT
OPTIONS.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
FEW STATES TO REGULATE TNC
STATEWIDE.
THUS THE SOLUTION TO TNC
DISABILITY ACCESS UNAVAILABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA WILL REQUIRE
STATEWIDE COORDINATION SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX MANDATES
THE P. YOU SEE DEVELOP
REGULATIONS FOR TNC
ACCESSIBILITY. FOR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING SS IN A
FEE ON TNC USED TO FUND ON
DEMAND WHEELCHAIR ACCESS
SERVICES COLLEGE DISABILITY
ACCESS TO TNC SHE SHOULD BE OF
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MEMBERS.
SENATOR I SEE YOU HAVE FO
WITNESSES I DO SUPPORT IT
[inaudible]
FRASER.
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AWESOME HE WAS WITH UBER --
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF FOR TAKING ON THIS
COMPLEX AT VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE --
WE'RE WORKING ON A PACKAGE OF
AMENDMENTS WITH THE I TAKEN WILL
GET A SKILLFUL SUPPORT POSITION --
JUST A SHORT BIT OF BACKGROUND
TEEN SEES SO MUCH A BILL
CONSIDERED EARLIER BY THE
COMMITTEE.
HAVE YOU SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
ON THE VEHICLES AND SO THE
SPECIALIZED WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE VEHICLES ARE ARE NOT
JUST A DIFFICULT THING TO GET ON
OUR PLATFORM BUT THEY ARE.
FOR YOU KNOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
OF BILL THIS ISSUE FOR DECADES.
WITH ONLY A FEW WAYS IN WHICH WE
CAN GET UP OF REALTORS HAS WILL
DECLINE A PLATFORM EITHER ONE
THAT'S PERSONALLY OWNED THAT
CHOOSE TO CONTRACT WITH UBER
LEFT.
WE CAN PARTNER WITH EXISTING
PARATRANSIT SERVICES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL OR WE CAN AT
ENTERTAINED ON ENGAGE IN
COMMERCIAL PARTNERSHIPS TO GET
THEM ON THE PLATFORM SO.
I THINK THAT THE MEMBERS IN THE
BILL THAT PROVIDES A FLEXIBLE
FEE STRUCTURE WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE FEE APPLIED TO OUR
BUSINESS --
DID IT AND IT IS ON THAT HE
DOESN'T YOU KNOW --
DISINCENTIVE I'D MAKE IT DIRECT
INVESTMENT IMPROVING SUPPLY.
AND THEN THE FACT THAT --
IF THE BILL I TAKES A REGIONAL
APPROACH THIS ISSUE OBVIOUSLY
MAKING SURE NO LEFT NOWHERE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEFT OUT BY THE
BILL.
WILL REQUIRE OBVIOUSLY A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF SERVICE PROVIDED IN THE
BAY AREA FOR EXAMPLE NEAR THE
NEAR THE SENATORS DISTRICT.
SHOULDN'T BE CONSIDERED IN THE
SAME -- FEE
STRUCTURE AS AS SOMETHING IN A
LIST OF THE THERE'S SORT OF A
COMPETITIVE BALANCE IN EVERY
PART OF THAT'S WHAT THIS WAS.
I'D JOHN ROSS ON BEHALF OF LEFT
HAD THIS IS ONE WHERE WE FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE CLEAR ALIGNMENT
WITH --
SENATOR HILL AND THAT PROPONENTS
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
FEW DETAILS TO WORK OUT IN THE
WORDS OF THE THAT WE FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL.
THINK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AARONSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT --
WE THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL
WOULD IMPROVE ACCESS.
NOT -- TO
VARIOUS DNC'S WILL SUPPLEMENT
OUR EXISTING TRANSIT SERVICES
THANK YOU ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
MISTER MEMBERS JOSHUA SHAW FOR
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE SAN FRANCISCO
MUNICIPAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
AND THE MAYOR'S OFFICE ON
DISABILITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
AGREE WITH THE STATEMENT MADE BY
THE JOINT FROM OVER THAT WHETHER
THE TNC PROVIDE THE SERVICES
DIRECTLY OR THROUGH THIS FEE
MECHANISM THEY'RE ABLE TO FIND
TEMPORARY SERVICES INCLUDING BY
CONTRACTING OUT.
THAT'S THE WAY TO PROVIDE EQUAL
ACCESS TO EVERYONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MONTH
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC.
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC LIGHT SPEAKING OPPOSITION
OR VOICE OUR OPINION OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
CENTER LOOKS CLOSE.
S. HERE I'VE OF MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR
FOR A BRING THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
AS YOU KNOW UP PROMOTING THIS IS
AT HE'S MAKES US BILLY FOR THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY IS A TRUE
PASSION OF MINE I SERVE ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION FOR
DISABILITY ACCESS.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND ASK YOU
TO CONTINUE WORKERS STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT ALL ALL WHO NEED
A RIDE ME ABLE TO GET.
ONE AND AGAIN ADDRESSING THE THE
DISPARITY NEED IN SOME OF THE
RULE COME COMMUNITIES OF WITH
PARA TRANSIT IS SO.
I THINK ABSOLUTELY PERFECT FOR
THE TNC IS TO BE A PART OF THAT.
GOING FORWARD AND SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY --
WE HAVE A FIRST UP BY.
HOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
SECOND TO NONE BY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON PLEASE OF
MEDS ARTICLES OR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FRASIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING MATHIS
[inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT IS SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO NEEDS ONE MORE.
TO GET OUT LEGAL ROLE OPEN
FRANKLY VERY MUCH IF YOU'RE A
SENATOR GRAHAM THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SENATOR MORNING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN SP
TWELVE THIRTY SIX OR PLEASE
PROCEED TO THE COLEMAN.
START WHEN YOU'RE A THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
A CURRENT LAW REQUIRES ANY
CALIFORNIA WHO WANTS TO DRIVE A
LARGE TRUCK PASSENGER BUS OR
OTHER COMMERCIAL VEHICLE. TO
OBTAIN A COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE BY SIMPLY PASSING A
WRITTEN TEST IN A SHORT DRIVING
TESTS ADMINISTERED BY THE DMV.
THERE'S NO EXISTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT APPLICANTS FOR A COMMERCIAL
DRIVER'S LICENSE RECEIVE ANY
INSTRUCTIONAL TRAINING OR EVEN
COMPLETE A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
HOURS OF TRAINING BEHIND THE
WHEEL.
BEFORE BEING LICENSED BY THE
STATE.
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES FIFTY HOURS
OF BEHIND THE WHEEL TRAINING
WHEN A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD SEEKS
THEIR FIRST DRIVER'S LICENSE.
YET WE REQUIRE NO MINIMUM HOURS
HAVE BEHIND THE WHEEL TRAINING
PRIOR TO LICENSING SOMEONE TO
DRIVE AND EIGHTY THOUSAND POUND
SEMI TRUCK ON PUBLIC STREETS AND
ROADS.
MEMBERS THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE IN
WITH UPWARDS OF FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE KILLED IN LARGE TRUCK
CRASHES EACH YEAR IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IT IS PARAMOUNT THAT WE
ESTABLISH MINIMUM STANDARDS.
TRAINING TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMERCIAL DRIVERS ARE SAFELY
OPERATING THERE VEHICLES ON THE
ROADS THEY SHARE WITH OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR CONSTITUENTS.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY SIX
WILL REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO COMPLY WITH THE
NEW FEDERAL RULE ESTABLISHED BY
THE FEDERAL MOTOR CARRIER SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT ESTABLISHES
NEW SAFETY AND TRAINING
STANDARDS FOR ALL ENTRY LEVEL
COMMERCIAL DRIVER APPLICANTS.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY SIX
WILL ADDITIONAL ESTABLISH A
MINIMUM REQUIREMENT OF FIFTEEN
HOURS A BEHIND THE WHEEL
TRAINING AS PART OF THOSE NEW
TRAINING STANDARDS.
IMPORTANCE OF COMMERCIAL DRIVER
TRAINING.
S. FIRST BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
WHEN I MET THE FAMILY. TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD DANIEL MCGUIRE
SANTA CRUZ WHO WAS TRAGICALLY
KILLED IN A TRUCK ACCIDENT.
ON HIGHWAY SEVENTEEN IT WAS
CAUSED BY A COMMERCIAL DRIVER
WHO WAS LICENSED BY THE STATE.
BUT WHO LACKS THE MOST BASIC
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO PROPERLY
OPERATE HIS FORTY TON TRUCK THAT
ULTIMATELY KILLED DANIEL IN
INJURED SEVEN OTHERS.
DANIEL'S FAMILY HAS BEEN BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE TWICE BEFORE TO
SHARE THEIR STORY IN THEIR HERE
IN THE AUDIENCE AGAIN TODAY. TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE OF THE REAL
CONSEQUENCES OF LICENSING
DRIVERS WITHOUT REQUIRING
ADEQUATE.
BEHIND THE WHEEL TRAINING
THROUGH THE BILL.
MEMBERS IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
ACT NOW TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMERCIAL DRIVERS ARE RECEIVING
COMPREHENSIVE.
AND EFFECTIVE TRAINING.
SUPPORTING SP TWELVE THIRTY SIX
TODAY YOU'LL BE HELPING US TO
TAKE THAT FIRST CRITICAL STEP.
SPEC FLASHED YOUR AYE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND MISTER
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN ABOUT A MINUTE
TRAIN UNION --
BOTH OF WHOM SUPPORT --
THIS BILL STRONGLY IT'S CRITICAL
TO HAVE BEHIND THE WHEEL
TRAINING FOR ANYBODY ON OUR
HIGHWAYS AND AS MR MONEY POINTED
OUT. EIGHTY THOUSAND POUND
VEHICLES ARE DIFFICULT TO DRIVE
AND PEOPLE SHOULD BE EXPERIENCED
WHEN THEY'RE ALLOWED TO BE
LICENSED.
WHICH PUT BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE PROMISED CHAIR
MEMBERS --
TIM CHIANG WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE DO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT SAFETY
MEASURE.
KRIS CONNOR PRISON THE OWNER
OPERATOR INDEPENDENT DRIVERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT PICK YOU.
I'M GAIL CHAMBER CHOIR
DANIELLE'S MOM AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME WAITING AND WE NEED TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
AND OUR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU MA'AM SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER MITCHELL
JENNIFER MITCHELL CONSULTING I
HAVE DECADES OF EXPERIENCE.
IN JOB TRAINING AND RELATED
POLICY AND I'M ALSO A FAMILY
FRIEND.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKES TESTIFIES FOR THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS HERE MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROBERT SPIEGEL
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
BASED ON THE MOST RECENT SET OF
AMENDMENTS --
FARM BUREAU HAS REMOVED HER
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE THIRTY
SIX AYE WE WOULD LIKE TO TO
THANK US SENATOR MONNING HIS
STAFF -- THE
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE STAFF UP
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
HI WALKING LARA AND DAMAGE WIRES
BEST FRIEND.
AND FROM THE FAMILY AND DIE
SUPPORT S. B. [inaudible]
TWELVE THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
ANYBODY IN THE PUBLIC THEY LIKE
TO TESTIFYING OPPOSITION VOICE
THEIR OPINION ON THE OTHERS BILL.
I THINK SO --
ANY -- MS
BAKER I WOULD SAY OF COURSE OF
THE AUTHOR.
IS TO THINK YOU KNOW I THINK THE
FAMILY AGAIN FOR COMING HERE NOT
ONCE AND TWICE BUT A THIRD TIME --
TO TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF NOW
YOUR SON BUT OTHERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU CENTER MINE
FOR CONTINUING TO PUSH THIS
ISSUE FULLY SUPPORT IT.
HELPING GET THIS WHEN THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK INSIDE THANK YOU.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE THE
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR WAS LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAKER FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER TONIGHT I HAVE
TO THANK.
THE OF THE FARM BUREAU.
AND MEMBERS OF YOUR STAFF
[inaudible]
HUB.
TWO OUR COMMITTEE INTEGRATED THE
PROCESS OF GETTING TO WHERE
WE'RE AT NOW AND AND THE AMEND
SIMPLY GETTING THEM TO PULL
THEIR OPPOSITION --
REALLY WILLOWS A WORKING --
TEAM TO GET THIS TO THIS POINT --
IT'S OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE
DRIVERS OF COMMERCIAL VEHICLES.
ARE PROBABLY TRAINED TO DRIVE
THOSE VEHICLES AS YOU SAID AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ANY
THOUSAND POUND VEHICLES.
IS A WHAT AT OF MASS DESTRUCTION
HAND --
BEHIND THE WHEEL --
COMPONENT IS NECESSARY FOR THAT
TRAINING ARE GOING FORWARD AGAIN
TO THE FAMILY AS A FATHER WHO
LOST A CHILD IN A CAR ACCIDENT.
I I REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUAL EFFORTS.
JUST KNOW THAT MY THOUGHTS ARE
WITH YOU.
I AM SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY SOME MEN
OF SECTOR WE'D GO SEE WE HAVE A
FIRST BY BERMAN SECOND AGREEMENT --
MINUTES EVERY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE DALY.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT'S ELEVEN ZERO
IT'S OUT LEAVE THE ROLE OF THE
TRAPS TO MEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS
MR CENTER.
SO MEMBERS ARE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND LIFT THE CALL MADAM
SECRETARY WE START.
THE PROCESS PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTE IS TEN TO ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I DALY [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE.
TWELVE TWO ZERO WHICH WE CALL
[inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
FILE ITEM.
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS.
FIVE TO ONE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER
[inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
CURRENT VOTE IS.
NINE TO ONE WE'RE GONNA MOVE
OVER TO THE FILE ITEM --
TWELVE WE WERE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
THAT SO MANY ENTERTAIN A MOTION
[inaudible]
HOW?
OF WILL FRIEDMAN AND A TRUCE AS
THE SECOND.
AMEND SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL ROTH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM SEVEN
SP ONE THOUSAND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT TO ZERO
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
DALY.
DALY AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARYAN.
CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT
SP.
TEN FOURTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTER SEVENTY THREE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I DALY [inaudible]
MATHIS.
FILE ITEM EIGHT S. B..
TEN FOURTEEN MATHIS NO NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE.
EIGHT TO FOUR FILE ITEM NINE THE
SP TEN TWENTY NINE THE CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I AM DALY
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING THAT THERE HAD.
CURRENT VOTE.
NINE TWO ZERO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY TO THE
CURRENT VOTERS ELEVEN TO ZERO
DALY.
DALY AYE NAZARIAN.
KERN VOTE.
TWELVE TO ZERO FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN SB ELEVEN FIFTY ONE
CURRENT VOTERS NINE TO ZERO
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A DAILY.
DALY AYE GIPSON [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
CURRENT VOTE. TWELVE TO ZERO
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SP ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
TO THREE BERMAN.
BERMAN NOT VOTING.
TO CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS KNOWN AS AREA
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I CURRENT VOTE.
EIGHT TO FOUR FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
SP TWELVE THIRTY SIX CURRENT
VOTERS ELEVEN TO ZERO DAILY.
DALY AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I NAZARIAN.
CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
CURRENT VOTED SEVEN TO ZERO
BERMAN.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY TWO FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN BERMAN I TO CHIU AYE
DALY.
DALY AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO FILE ITEM
NINETEEN S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TO TWO
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I DALY.
DALY AYE MATHIS.
VIOLATE IN NINETEEN S. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY MATHIS NO MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE IN THIS AREA
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I CURRENT EVENT. NINE
TO THREE FILE ITEM TWENTY SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ AREA.
CURRENT VOTE TEND.
TO ZERO VIOLATING TWENTY ONE SP.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE THIS AREA
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE [inaudible]
WHAT?
WE JUST WENT THROUGH THE WHOLE
THING [inaudible]
LET ME [inaudible] FOR ABOUT
.
FILE ITEM NINE S. B. TEN TWENTY
NINE DALY.
DALY AYE.
CURRENT VOTE TEND.
TO ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TO ZERO DALY.
DALY AYE CURRENT VOTE.
THIRTEEN TO ZERO LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE NOW
COMPLETE THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED